what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
that pregame
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos if you
want to see exclusive behind-the-scenes
content sign up for our memberships and
all super chats will be read today i
have a lovely panel of lovely guests so
why don't we go around everyone say your
name age
relationship status and where you're
from
starting with me yes okay welcome back
thank you nana evans 42
married
and live in east london
content sign up for our members
yeah um hi my name is jesse praise i
work at a hedge fund and make videos on
youtube and
take talk
i'm 24 years old
and
i am
married to my bible
wow
okay
hi everyone my name is iman i'm 21 years
old i'm single and i'm moroccan
yo what's going on peeps is rants the
enigma age and relationship status
unknown
[Laughter]
nice one
i'm daley i'm 26 from the domino effect
podcast and relationship state is taken
yeah i'm eddie i'm 26 26 i'm 28 um the
other half of the domino fit podcast the
most valuable host
okay so today's topic is something that
i have seen on this podcast and just in
my day-to-day life
and that is the victim mindset and
victim mentality of modern women
so the example i use of this is
something that's happened a couple times
in this podcast i've had men and women
both go viral on this podcast for the
wrong reasons okay
people come on the show and they'll wild
out
and what happens is the men i never hear
from they just kind of take the owl and
move on
but the women will come to me and start
blaming me for their bad behavior on the
podcast and for going viral for the
wrong reasons
why do men take accountability for their
actions where women always seem to point
the finger i'd like to hear from the men
first
uh i guess i should go first and
somebody but
i think
that there is from a young age as a boy
man
you're somewhat
held accountable from from then you know
so if you do something wrong especially
i'm nigerian so if you did something
wrong you're hearing from your dad when
you come home you gotta think so you
know you you're told very early on your
consequences your actions have
consequences and so you need to
make sure that you don't do the wrong
things in order to not have those
consequences but a lot of times
i do think certain cultures don't have
that same energy when it comes to women
and that might be why
okay
yeah i just think self-awareness in it i
feel like as a man you're forced to have
that you know i mean from early days
when you're in the playground you know
i'm saying if you're fat you're the
goalkeeper
it just is what it is you know i'm
saying like you get picked last if
you're not the guy no one complains like
everyone kind of knows like there's
always there's an accountability there's
a hierarchy amongst men like we just
know from early like where we kind of
fit in in it like we live in a world
where
we get shown and told where we are all
the time and what what we are in it and
i just feel like for women there isn't
really that but i think their friends
just lie to them too much
leading on from that as well i think
it's self-awareness
if you're a man and you're short fat and
you're broke the world will tell you as
soon as you enter the dating marketplace
where you enter the world on what your
status is whereas a woman if you're if
you're overweight you'll probably have a
body body positivity group say that it's
the right way to be
so i think there's a lot of ways to
mummy cuddle women where there is men
aren't afforded that luxury
well to emulate what the mandom said um
yeah men are forced to have to live in
in reality from young
girls growing up are just never told no
so they grew up with this idea that you
know the world kind of revolves around
them so
that's why i mentioned that you know men
have to create their value for our life
our women are are giving their value
so with that you're afforded two
different mentalities as you're growing
up and going through life and
that allows women to
to operate from this facade of what the
reality shows so when anything goes
against that that kind of
cognitive dissonance there's a there's a
compactiveness there was that
so um question for the women is is it
just me is this just something that i
see where women don't take as much
accountability as men do
or have you seen that in real life like
do you agree do you disagree
um you can start okay i kind of
partially agree but at the same time
there was uh something that the last guy
said that just triggered something in me
like that that's just not true like i
think women do take accountability and
they are shaped
from young as well the levels of
accountability are very different and i
definitely agree
um the fantasy spin
i think is very feminine and they're
kind of like i'm gonna uh i'm gonna
reshape reality i think that is a
feminine trait but that doesn't mean
that both sexes don't have an issue with
accountability i absolutely think that
there is an issue with accountability in
society for all sexes at this moment
where do you see that men don't take
accountability
i think men don't take accountability
for the
this status and um
actual kind of weight that they have put
on themselves and they complain about it
like it's women that have kind of put
this weight on their shoulders and how
they should shape their reality is like
because of women and and women don't
have that same pressure i think they've
done that to themselves can i have a
specific example i'm just i don't
understand what you're talking about
even just being like okay so i
the role of being the breadwinner or the
one that has to provide everything i
think that is men that have put that on
themselves i don't think that has
anything to do with women you don't
think you don't think that has anything
to do with women when women want a guy
that makes um at least 30 percent more
than them
no i i don't think there are that many
women that think that like that no no
it's if you survey women and ask them
they want a man that makes at least 30
percent more than that
and if and if a woman one of the number
one indicators of divorce is if a woman
out earns the man this is the thing
would that not come from men 100 what
would they not be the ones that are not
comfortable no no because because the
women initiate divorce so women leave is
70 to 80 no no 70 to 80 of the time
women leave and 90 of their college
educated so the higher up a woman goes
in terms of income and status the more
likely she leaves okay now you're saying
she's leaving because she's earning more
and no i'm saying that she may be like
i'm not satisfied in this relationship
because
he has an issue with me earning more and
i don't want to stay in this dynamic so
from from what i've seen in the guys you
can maybe correct like you can tell me
what you've seen because you guys you
know you i i see the girls
i i found when girls move up in in
making money they're around more men
that make more money than them so i
think
on some level they kind of wish they
were with the men they were working with
rather than their husbands
and so they kind of see what they're not
getting and then they they leave
i i can see that in some circumstances
but i actually think the troubles in a
house when a woman is earning more
isn't necessarily about that dynamic
this goes back to women's women's nature
so yeah we've all heard the term
hypergamy so women are married for
across up social hierarchies so
naturally women are programmed to always
get the best that they can get so at the
time when she got married her man that
might have been the best that she could
get at the time but as she elevates
herself past him then she's in a new tax
bracket with new men who are at a higher
level therefore that her pergamos nature
starts to kick in again and says i can
do better than what i currently have
neglecting that the man
in this situation is also contributing
to the dynamic of that relationship
there's contributing and is acting on it
so yes a man wouldn't divorce a woman
necessarily because she always wanted
him whereas
because she wouldn't but it may be hell
in that and this is the part that nobody
is going into so should she stay in a
house where it's hellish but this is the
thing to have hold on where are we going
because i just feel like the gold pulse
just got moved to like to where that is
it tends to be that if a man's earning
less than his wife he tends to be more
passive so what are the chances that he
would actually be
and you also have to think about this
logically as well what if we're talking
about such a higher percentage figure of
70 percent of women leave but the more
high educated more money they make you
can't then argue like logically that
most of those situations have got the
man's given her health she's doing
better for herself
why is there not surveys on actually the
reasons why the dominant reason for one
is financial in a second is infidelity
yeah so women leave for financial
reasons
women and men and women and men cheat at
similar rates it's like 23 26 the
financial reasons that are cited could
that not literally be that we had
disharmony in our house because i was
earning more
but this is the thing though because you
know or what type financial reasons are
you talking about
the finances aren't enough so she has to
leave and find better because a lot of
times a lot of times women don't like to
have to do more work in terms of that
you know but what pay for bills but what
so the initial question was you said men
are held accountable and they put that
on themselves but what i'm saying is i
think the data indicates that men are
held accountable for this because if
your woman out earns you she's out the
door
so they they men have to deal with a
consequence quick
where women where if a woman if a woman
gains a bunch of weight in a marriage
which to me is like similar to the
equivalent like usually the men don't
leave i don't know what they're saying
what you're saying if a woman puts on
weight it's the same as if she earns
more no i'm saying like i think that the
equivalent of a woman a woman gave a
hundred pounds is like a man losing a
job and refusing to work mm-hmm i would
say it's something
full of attraction instead of what what
we are what we're attracted to
okay because we women are attracted to
money money and status whereas men
we're visual creatures yeah okay so if
you take the visual aspect away from it
then
that's when they start treating with
cheating with the secretary and it gets
all happening i can kind of
see where that's going i i half kind of
agree yeah so what i'm saying is is
women don't seem to fit like i don't
know a lot of men in real time that are
leaving their woman because she gained
weight
but i do know a lot of women that out
earn their boyfriends or their husbands
and leave so what i'm saying is women
don't face the consequence and then men
do
no i totally disagree with you i can't
see how this even makes sense
because it's frowned upon when men do
certain things so you know if i leave my
wife because she's fat everyone is going
to hate on me yeah you'll get shamed for
one thing i would say but you do that
all the time you'll get shameful you
can't even call you can't even call
women in fact now but they can call you
short though
what is it but this is just how it is
you have to remember as well we're not
talking like anecdotal we're talking
statistical data to prove what's going
on
listen statistics are the same thing as
an anecdote you have to collect the data
points and that is through sight the
person has to actually be collating the
data so they're going to go and get the
data
is then it's just whatever like and i
hear this a lot from women where it's
like we can't trust the data but then
what do we trust we just each
individually know where the data has
come from you need to know the sample
you need to know the sample sizes come
from heaven
when it's convenient for them because
yeah i'm sure when there's a cause that
you know you feel for and the data i am
like forcing what you think no you
wouldn't say if you wanna if you wanna
question individual studies fine if you
wanna go in and maybe
inspect the data more fast like i i
i say everyone has the right to do that
but with with the divorce statistics
it's pretty it's pretty cut and dry
i'm literally like but what are the
reasons and saying financial i'm like
yeah it could be financial but what was
the dynamic of the relationship where
finances were cited but even so we know
yeah
but finances do they do affect it
because
most women if you earn less than them
there's a certain level of respect they
just won't give you
and you know what i'm saying and you're
not speaking to me a certain way in my
house not happening they'll support you
for like a period of time but there are
dynamics that i'm more interested in
like that
that that kind of thought like so then
respect was of course there's a certain
level of respect a woman is not going to
give you if she knows she's out earning
it
because she had the money she can get a
lawyer and she can leave i understand
that and i have nothing against that
it's just to be like a woman is leaving
because she's earning more no what's the
reasons why and because she's going to
be here
okay so but there has to be a disharmony
and that is because this army is the
fact she's earning more well but where's
the level of that would it not be
because the man is feeling honestly
about it but she's leaving you all
living in the show okay so i've ever so
this is what i've seen and guys i mean
from the men's point of view you can
tell me if this is accurate or
inaccurate i found if a girl let's say a
girl gets a promotion she's making half
a million a year is she going to submit
to the guy and say you get to make all
the financial decisions in the house
it's impossible
do you guys feel like most girls that
you've dated would be cool with you
being a hundred percent in charge of the
money if they're out earning yeah
a lot of women would be idealistic and
say no i would like i would still like
you to make all the decisions but when
it becomes more practical and she's the
breadwinner the dynamics change really
fast because then she's trying to tell
you mate watch the dishes that's it
i'm working hella hours and i'm not
going to come home to a dirty kitchen
right now this is gross
it's like most men would say oh if my
wife put on weight after having kids
that i'm going to be with her forever
and never cheat but when she's looking
like 200 pounds heavier and then your
sexy sex tree comes in you might slip
into a vagina by accident
bro
you're loyal but bro it's the madness
and also yeah like updated women here
that make good money maybe not more than
me but good money and most women don't
like spending money on you anyway so it
don't matter how much you make i'm not
even gonna lie because i always end up
spending the majority of the money in
the relationship regardless they spend
their money on themselves as many always
deployed the idea that your money is
your money as a woman but my money's out
our money yeah that's how it works see
it differently 100 especially if you
come from that kind of upbringing in it
so i always i'll always pay most of the
time so these girls are living life
they're going on holiday with their
friends with the money that they should
be spending on man
you know what i mean
what's she doing on that holiday
you know what i'm saying
you know what i'm saying but what's up
you know better though i do think that's
mental if you have a girl that's not
spending on you and you're still with
her that's that's your problem what are
you gonna do run her down for a pee is
that what you're on i'm sorry if if
she's with you and you're she's not
doing anything not paying for anything
at all not even one day that's on you so
what you're sitting at the table and
you're saying to my man with a chip
saying you'll bring that over there
my birthday my wife doesn't take me out
it's finished yeah but if you're if
you're a nice girl that's actually into
usual often
bro i'm sure i'm sure all of you have
had at some point a girl that that
that's obsessed with you yeah
when you're seeing a pattern of her not
just offering and not actually doing
it's on you to then be like okay she's
not actually doing this why should i do
the same because that's character what
do you mean by characters that's her
character then so i think it's on the
man but that's what i'm saying
yeah i'm agreeing with you if you're
with somebody and that's their character
that they are inherently selfish
where's the accountability and i picked
a super selfish person but going back to
the five like earning half a meal
is that fair that i would be earning the
half a meal and you get to make all the
decisions of course it's not well it's
not it's not fair but what the problem
is is when you start leading in a
relationship we're not attracted to a
guy that we can just like that's whipped
questions
so i think there's more of a
shared pot
if i'm the breadwinner it goes into a
shared pot i don't think i would turn
over what i'm earning
and then somebody else who isn't earning
the same is like this is how it's being
spent
i understand what she's saying this is
what i'm saying about the respect thing
do you know what i'm saying this is the
thing so actually i have a question for
you so um you said accountability for
picking the wrong partner
um do you feel the same way about women
that pick cheaters and or abusers yeah
okay so so you you believe it's equal
you're accountable for the people that
you pick yeah yeah yeah it's vibrational
okay
i need to elaborate on that one it's
vibrational i think that after you've
gone through it
when you come out of it
there has to be some type of
accountability i think if you do i
how did that happen how did i allow it
to take place what was taking place in
the dynamics of the relationship and i
was there it's still on the person who
did the cheating because they did the
act but you there is some type of
complicitness to it and if you take the
person back and you stay with them and
they do it again yeah it's your fault i
i i agree
do you think most women think that way
no no i actually
okay
no okay outwardly okay but i think
internally they actually beat themselves
up and they do but then they gain the
same situation again so what does that
say because vibrationally they haven't
learned but what do you mean by yeah
you need two people that are in
attraction to each other so they are
still in a lack they're still in an
insecurity and the person knows i can do
this to this person because they are not
full of themselves but maybe they just
like of that because i i one thing i've
noticed a lot with girls is that you
know you'll be of a guy who's a scammer
you'll be able to guys are drug dealing
and then complain when he scams you and
cheats
we pull our reflections on bro so if
you're if you are attracted to a scammer
you are a scammer
of course because if you're okay with
him doing that then you're doing it i
know when he stands on you
if you get cheated on it's your own
fault like you picked up it definitely
it should be that way but this is where
i see the problem with self-awareness in
a modern society a lot of people claim
to be self-aware and understand
themselves but they really they don't if
you're making those decisions and then
complaining about the outcome of those
decisions it doesn't make sense so a lot
of girls look for avenues to absorb
themselves the responsibility of the
problems that they create one of them is
western western horoscopes ah you know
your star sign is this so he's an area
i'm saying yeah i'm here so it goes back
to that idea of accountability it's like
women are never told no or to
or held accountable in the sense that
you've got a girl as an individual to
get to to grow out of this
yeah yeah they don't have to
self-develop because if they look good
someone else will pick them up in it but
i think i think there's a growing
population of men that are the exact
same you know they don't take
accountability for the things they're
doing you know
it might be because exactly becoming
more feminine it's the same thing a guy
will go for girls that um you know only
wants it for money and then be
complaining that girls only wonder for
money it doesn't make sense i don't know
about that one mm-hmm i've seen i've
seen a lot of guys come back guys guys
with money don't complain about spending
it but that's the thing it's only broke
brother
you've got broke friends i hear it
trust me
my name is peace will never complain
that i'm spending money on a girl no
because they know they know what it is
they know it's transactional anyway but
it depends on what you want so again if
you're trying to look for marriage you
don't want a girl that's just taking you
for money no it doesn't make sense most
men won't care if you as long as
if you've got money and she's pretty
more time you're going to ignore a lot
of the bad characteristics so you don't
have to deal with them see you you only
have to deal with those when you're when
you're an average guy
with a with a girl that's that women are
naturally hypergamous
there's a lot more wiggle room for her
to push limits when you're a guy with
money you can just tell it to shut up i
think it depends on how you got your
money because there is a difference
between a successful man and a high
value man yes i in my job i work with
rich people every single day
like hedge fund managers or partners in
firms
their wants are very different how many
how many how many divorces of most of
the guys
cap
divorce is the less the richer man is
exactly right they've also left the rich
they want different things you know a
man who's successful because he's a
rapper or a singer he wants different
things that i'm only successful because
he he works
i think that's down to the fact that the
woman sees that what that she's found a
resource that she can't let go of but so
she doesn't act in a way that a woman
with less than would act but not
necessarily because i think that makes
sense that makes sense but then also
those men are looking for different
things so
when you let's say you're a hedge fund
manager you're not just looking for a
girl who's pretty when you want to marry
you look for most of them their wives
are doctors um they work in finance
they're lawyers there's a reason for
that because they're not just looking
for going for looks
all of my brothers like make six figures
and they they they dump girls for being
too dumb all the time like my brother
wouldn't date teachers in college like
he because he just felt like they
weren't smarter
he's probably going to marry an engineer
and that's why they talk about hypergamy
as has no one wants to talk about it's
leading to the wealth gap becoming even
wider because before when women couldn't
work naturally there would be equal
equilibrium where all the women couldn't
work they'd go for a man who who worked
and then there would always be that
socio economic gap between them
now you've got these high achieving
women that refuse to date anyone below
them socially economically so what
you're leading to is
the powerful women who are earning a lot
of money are stealing or taking the high
earning men which is leaving less so
it's leading to a higher wealth
inequality growth but are they taking
the higher earning because a lot of
these women complain they ain't got
enough time to go gym because they're
always working but men don't want that
i might be real majority of um half of
women over 30 are single and childless
that's what i mean they're not going so
they're not going there like so they're
single bro yeah i mean a large
proportion of women are by them damn
selves
but that's irrespective of the career
they're in that's not necessarily just
because they're in the you know higher
power
i think it's definitely because when you
look at women who work in the nursing
sector they're going to have way higher
marriage rates than someone who works
and say a headphone who's a woman no of
course
women who are professionals tend to
delay marriage and children and family
because of course they know it's been
detrimental to their career yeah of
course but i i do think in general the
statistic that women less women are
getting married is across yeah yeah yeah
i agree with that yeah so
um another so another area where i hear
girls lack accountability nowadays
let's let's talk about the church
if if a girl has a whole face why does
the women get to blame it on the men
pressuring her or get to blame it on her
being broken
and at 28 29 find god
and resave herself for marriage with a
husband get out of here
yo
but but if a man sleeps around and has a
whole face
nobody
what man having a whole face well you
know what if i mean they say like go sow
your wild oats in your 20s right they'll
say yeah they'll say you know go around
do your thing as a guy in your 20s but
he doesn't get to blame it on his
brokenness he it's just just that he was
corny yeah but a girl
she could say i was so broken i was so
lost and at 28 29 right when i'm running
out of time now is my time to find god
trying to find myself seriously who
takes some seriously when they say no
but this is
this is where men have to take
accountability and i mean the simpy men
who the reality is they're allowed to do
that because simpy men allow it and
usually those kind of women who find god
end up with that guy that wasn't their
plan a it was probably their plan zed
but bro that's not necessarily their
fault because if you're gonna be real
here we already know the small
percentage of men that actually get play
anyway these men are just grateful for
an opportunity to set it up to be on the
pitch you know that one's there it's
like you're the manager called man up
yeah everybody's one minute left at
added time i just want to get out there
you know like that's what i want to i
just want to stretch my legs under my
nose
sure i'll wait even though you got two
kids from two different babies that's
what i'm saying i might not touch the
bull yeah but i can boy it's another cap
you know what i'm saying so the man out
here saying you know what i've been
waiting so i'm gonna get out here and
this is what it is when they're younger
they do all the madness and then some
sucker ends up picking them up
but he's happy he's not a sucker he's
happy though no but he's happy until
his decision until until she gets the
kids and he has a sexless marriage
because she's not attracted to him that
was his decision that's it you should
have known about that before he went
into the a lot of sims don't know that
though yeah that's what i'm saying i
think a lot of guys don't know the games
like how would they know they haven't
dealt with women but again so when a
girl when a girl comes in at 28 29 and
she says i was so broken like this was
like he believes her because he doesn't
he doesn't know these girls are crazy
but i think the problem is the
information's out readily available now
yeah if you don't know that that's on
you you know that's on you not doing
your research yeah but when you're
actually in it and you've never had
everyone knows like you know when you
when you're young if you used to get in
like you know when you're 15 you have
that one girl that she violated and you
learn from that when you're like 15 and
all the olders will tell you she's doing
a magazine but you know you're like no i
like this girl and you learn but these
men are learning in their 30s but again
once they're married men are told by the
elders oh she's doing a madness and
still won't listen they choose not to
listen
because their options weren't let's do
that man but this is what i'm saying
though you can't just keep saying as a
younger because you know it's on you
what you decide i think this just goes
down to a lot of men ain't disciplined
just plain and simple yes a lot of us we
think with our willies you know i'm
saying no not a lot of us have taken the
time out again we've meant to get to
know ourselves so that you don't
remove yourself from certain situations
because cool like you said i know my
name on the block when i was young that
when they like their wife are not
greases this girl slept with the whole
block but because she slept with me that
means there must be something there
there must be something there yeah
i know
it's easier to turn down food here when
you know when you where your next meals
come in you understand what i'm saying
bro like these men ain't had nothing
like their whole life they got no play
they probably spent their 20s
watching and listening to their virgins
talk about the madness they were doing
and then
and then they see a girl that they know
is out of their league now do you know
what i mean and all of a sudden she's
interested someone's like right it's my
time do you know what i'm saying so
man's gonna deal with all the nonsense
okay i think that goes to people not
knowing the value because so so when
does accountability step in now because
you guys are using totally different
terms like you're leaving out all of the
accountability when on a woman
i don't think i am where's it you you
absolutely no we just said simply men
need to be accountable though we
literally all said it no you used a
different term what you said is that you
said it was that they're not disciplined
that's right accountability so can we be
like that scenario
the whole point is men deal with the
consequences because men get the
consequences
he's got a wife that's ran through and
there's consequences that come with a
wife that's ran through and he might
no but you're right and i'm not but the
point is that women in society can do
what they want and there's no
consequence so no no okay
let me finish so i'm saying she gets to
do her thing in her whole face and she
still gets a ring and she still gets
kids with it with a husband the man
he
when he marries a hoe she divorces him
is the consequence of a woman doing that
the fact that she doesn't get the man
she wants what the consequence of a
woman being run through and you know
used up or whatever and then getting
married but to a guy that she doesn't
want isn't that a consequence i think
the kid's more important than that is
that a concept that's not a concept i
think it's a consequence because she'll
just leave manchester united yeah
because she's because she just leaves
him after the kids and then goes back to
the street exactly
exactly what kim done kim literally got
kanye do you know what i'm saying i've
got the four youths yeah i've got a
little mixed race babies i'm cut are you
mad and now she's with people yeah yeah
yeah
and she'll take half you know what i'm
saying she'll take half
yeah
she's like have you forgotten the taking
heart bro they're not getting divorced
bro i promise you they're going to stay
married i wanted to get you what alimony
is a woman a woman gets money just for
being married to a guy for a long time
i don't understand you can get a job in
some cases
dr dre's wife did you see how much she's
paying for her phone bills she lost her
mercy she was asking for more
and i don't understand because you can
get a job like why are you entitled to
his money because the laws are archaic
that's why but they're married women we
weren't talking about married women
leaving we were talking about somebody
who had been run through on the streets
that had two kids and they now managed
to find a room yeah a ring so that's
married yeah so now she's married to the
dude but yeah he's not the father of her
kids
right i mean she might give him more
kids i don't know yeah
look at sierra look at sierra she's
probably going to be cool with that what
she's probably going to be cool okay
let's take with the next guy that she is
with well that's i mean look at sierra
what happened with her
so what did she do she she got ran
through by future ran through all the
rappers
finds god 28 29 settles down with
russell wilson it seems okay for a
little bit now what's she doing she's
twerking on instagram the disrespect
yeah this man
so she's not able to twerk now like
she's no you shouldn't she was an artist
well she said she said she found god so
she gave russell wilson the impression
she waited a year to sleep with him and
she gave him the impression that she was
a changed woman
now after she gets the kids and the
resources she's twerking on instagram i
think that's disrespectful as a wife
there are things you can do when you are
single that i don't think you should do
if you are married preach no so i think
it's between her and her man and he
doesn't seem to care that she's twerking
and whatever that goes against you and
that's why okay guys what do you what
would you call him how do you know
how do you know that he doesn't mind i
feel like he just he don't have a say
like it's not that he doesn't mind like
my man's doing the offer fist i'm
telling you that's like he's not like
can i just say something he doesn't have
a say because there was a video where
she was literally getting ready and i
think i saw it yesterday also and like
she was getting ready and he was like
sierra we gotta go and she was ignoring
him
like like he's all over when you're
going out with your husband you take
your time and they are gonna be like
let's leave now and you are gonna be
like there's a certain level of
disrespect that happened there that only
a man that is aware can see that what's
happening
could i ask you a question do you like
masculine or feminine men masculine men
sure so so i'm confused so like with
what we're describing you seem to be
quite okay with a lot of the way a lot
of these women behave because do you
feel like you could behave that way with
a masculine man it's the dynamics of
being in a relationship like literally
you are going to be running late as a
woman it's going to happen and the guy
is going to be like let's leave now and
you're still going to be getting ready
sorry so this is what we mean about
accountability all you're doing right
now is giving excuse after excuse after
it's giving you to get away with it i'm
giving you an opportunity
for the woman to get away with the bad
behavior that she's clearly portrayed
but and it's funny because whenever
you're when i get back whenever whenever
something for the man comes up you
always try to put accountability on him
and then take it off for women because
yeah there's too much one-sidedness on
the woman being all accountable and it's
like but what about the man well i think
it even because society always takes
accountability off of women but it
doesn't oh my goodness okay okay
okay guys would name one double standard
outside of body count that does not
benefit women
you give me one and i'll be able to
disprove it because what one that does
benefit women we get drinks for free we
get free on the first week we get into
clubs for free
women women
like from at bars from men we get our
first
there are specific grants that are
offered to women that are not offered to
men there are women's shelters there are
not men
not not they're not that go out to to no
no no there is not there is not specific
there are not specific grants for white
males what specifically what should that
be why should there be they have higher
suicide rates that could possibly be one
reason yeah and there may be and so i
know that because the water privilege is
going their way and they know that it's
not equal in all the privileges excuse
me my my brothers are white males so i
don't i don't i'm giving you another but
i'm saying i'm saying i've had i've had
two brothers that tried to commit
suicide
reasons but and i'm saying it's not they
didn't try to commit suicide because and
i'm not sorry i don't try to bring in
personal situations i shouldn't do that
but but like it's not because like they
they were thinking oh i have privileges
it's because life can be hard as a man
there's
there's a lot of privileges offered to
women that men do not get and i'm giving
you examples but it's like i'm asking
i'm asking you with white men
and why they should be getting no no i
said i said this is a privilege that
women get that men don't often get um
as well
what does that have to do with anything
because grants are given to people who
are 18 to 25. so somebody over that can
they be like oh no they're okay rights
are given to people all the time with
grant circuit okay let's take quotas
that's across all ages so i'm giving you
specific examples where women are
benefited and men are not so there are
quotas that's at any age that are given
to women that are not offered to men so
i'm saying give me an example of a
privilege that is given to women that is
not given to men outside of body count
you can't don't say sleeping around one
double standard that does not benefit
that does not benefit women
i'm trying to think of one yeah
because i kind of think of like all of
the different disparities that are there
and i could say that that's why let's
look for answers
women get three times the amount of jail
sentencing for the same crime that men
do
women can go to the police you mean men
get yeah
i'm sorry sorry sorry reverse yeah yeah
i can get three times the amount of
sentencing for the same crime that women
do women can go to the police and say he
hit me and they'll take him to prison
that's sure so so i'm asking like where
then all of that gets screwed when you
add in a black person into there
but today but so you're moving the goal
post no no because we're talking we're
talking about we're talking about gender
right now we are talking about what i'm
saying it's very different so everyone
can only talk as a black woman but but
even it's very different within the
black community if a black man does
something and a black woman does
something it's not the same treatment is
different no no
let's give a real example so if me and
you was on the street right now me and
you yeah and you slapped me
is anybody gonna react
if i slap you what's gonna happen next
yeah it's a madness
example dundin that's the privilege that
you're trying to but they're different
i am a black woman and i could still get
done for that but also there is the
strength issue in there as
but when well woman hits a man so we all
agree that men are stronger than women
yeah of course yeah if i hit you and you
hit me the effects are going to be very
difficult
that's the thing okay right because
that's the nuance of it no no okay okay
let's have an example you go up and you
punch dwayne the rock johnson in the
face he's stronger than you
yeah yeah does anyone feel bad for you
when you get hit back nope
why do women get an excuse if a weak man
hits a strong man and gets hit back
nobody feels bad for him why is it that
if a weaker woman hits a stronger man
and she gets hit
again said again so if a woman hits a
man no
your argument was strength so you said
you said women women are not as strong
as men yeah but i'm saying so if he goes
up to dwayne the rock johnson big jack
dude yes and
and hits dwayne first yeah nobody is
going to feel bad for him when he gets
knocked the [ __ ] out because you
shouldn't have messed with him why do
women feel like it's acceptable
in fact i wake up at night because i'm
stupid
from the issue i'm not saying that women
should go around hitting men like
absolutely a man and he hits you back
you hit him first yes but the point is
because he is stronger the penalties are
going to be harder but it shouldn't be
the law
right
but the point is it doesn't is it but
but the whole point was i asked you for
a double standard that doesn't benefit
women outside sleeping around okay so i
get that yeah and the the counter that i
was offering is because there is the
weakness of a woman so when she hits a
man
why it's not seen as as impervious as a
man hitting a woman
is the strength
would i get less time one more time
because are you stronger than me both of
you are men and you because he's
stronger than me it doesn't but you
should actually know about men and women
okay so as i'm the weaker one yes but
i'm weaker than him so is he going to
get more time because
no it's going to be two black men and
you're going to move but that's the
point that's the point we're trying to
make it's not about strength it's about
what we're trying to say that you've
contradicted your argument
what if i was skinny and she was
stronger than me she could deadlift
bench more than me well there's some big
women out there
that nuance should be taken but it won't
should be
look what you're saying people will
laugh and laugh and say you got punched
by a girl they'll be laughing so what so
what are we gonna do so like if if a man
and a woman are fighting what are they
gonna do put them both on the scale what
if she weighs more than me
then what does it mean bro then i
knocked her out that's possible
it shouldn't that's sexist i think like
it should not i if you if you should
gender shouldn't you know let me let me
let me finish let me finish okay i'm
saying gender should not be taken into
consideration if you hit anybody you
should expect to get hit back and the
law should let you say that you were
acting in self-defense but i'm saying
but i'm saying that's not how it is
if i hit him and then you knocked me out
how who would the police think is
proportionate though no but i'm saying
if if it was dwayne the rock johnson
sitting here and he hit dwayne the rock
johnson and then he hit him back and
gets knocked out the police would ask
questions they wouldn't just assume
arguments like this is is why amber her
can do what she did
arguments like that is what amber can do
what she's doing because you can't be
saying that oh i hit you but i didn't i
didn't really hit you did i i'm a girl
so
i
that's what it's about like you knew you
couldn't hit harder than me when you hit
me you know what i mean and then you got
a receipt for your purchase and now what
you say you know what i'm saying it
doesn't make sense sorry we're using
extremes to accentuate the point
you can't just say because you're a
woman and you know statistically you're
you're less strong than i am that if you
hit me you didn't intend to hurt me as
much i am given a reason for why the law
but that's that's not why that's not why
it's just because
society cuddles with certain women and
the law should have been like it's got
nothing to do with strength no it should
it shouldn't it shouldn't though
whether it does or not we don't know
whether it does probably say it
shouldn't
but that is why it is there but if you
want equality why not you i'm not using
it again i'm not talking about you
specifically but if feminists want
equality why they're not fighting to
speak to feminists about it but because
i'm not about equality i'm about equity
and that's very different right but the
whole point is like i'm asking you to
name a double standard that doesn't
benefit women because you're not quite
getting what you're talking about
i don't think there is that's the truth
that that's the truth so i i have a stat
for you guys harvard so this is you
would you say harvard can gather
research effectively it depends what
islam oh god
the numbers are skewed
harvard says 70
of abuse is women against men
why do we why do we only hear about
violence against women because men don't
talk about it enough yeah
men don't really complain too much
they'll just take it
and why are there more women's shelters
than men because of the consequence of
the violence no i don't i don't think
well not think about what you just said
it's a contradiction
but it's more worthwhile
what kind of we talk about
are you talking about
are you talking about homeless shelters
and that because if it is stuff like
that as well even with the homelessness
in london because i always do like
um
do stuff for the homeless every year and
that and you never really see women on
the street and it's always and there's a
lot of white men on the street as well
so it's not just a thing where it's like
well if you're a man you can be homeless
i believe i'm saying i'm saying i'm
saying there's women's shelters but
there's not men's shelter yeah but what
kind of show is that what i'm saying
because i know i know there's also
women's battered women there's also
women's homeless shelters as well so
like they get taken into certain places
that men don't yes
i'm saying battered there's battered
women's shelters and at those shelters
they actively turn down men whoa
so we're sorry go ahead yeah i was just
i was just commenting on what he said
that we find more uh homeless men than
women
it's it's it's just because
we would take care of women more than
them
right because but then it goes back to
like women don't face consequences if a
man's on the street he's homeless if the
women's on the street there are many
more shelters and resources for her yeah
this is that's an interesting point
because i think there is you know people
talk about that glass ceiling but
there's like a cushioned floor that
women tend to go to
where men don't so if i'm if i'm poor i
have as a man i know that no woman is
going to marry and marry me and you know
raise me up and put me in the house but
that there's a possibility that it could
happen to you as a woman
so so you don't know about homosexuals
you don't know about that
men who don't what's the what's that
what's the probability of that happening
so what what what is the probability of
that there are bare men that don't have
housing and they literally find women
who have a child and they can move into
their house and that is a so so you're
right that that definitely is a thing
but it's a very small percentage of men
that can do that remember like i think
you've been here when i've talked about
these stats
okay okay so eighty percent of women
actually it's a hundred percent of women
want twenty percent of men
so if you look at and we have the data
to back this up because you have a
dating app i get
yeah so it's a very small part there are
a subset of men that do do that there
are the tinder swindlers out there
they're they're absolutely awesome
and they tend to attend
literally it's like a normal guy yes
road guy yes we'll turn up here he
provided the thing correct but do you
remember if we survey women it's they
find 90 of men unattractive or 80
percent of men on it i can't remember
the exact number between 80 and 90 of
men unattractive like you show a woman
10 men she'll say eight or nine of them
no yeah so it's it's a very small
percentage of men that could
get a woman's interest to begin with so
if you add on get
to get like free rent from her like what
percentage is
you're correct you are correct that does
happen but what i'm saying is often
times i think when we're trying to make
a point you're arguing an exception not
the rule yeah and and this is it's not
just you this is like i i women do this
on my show all the time when we're
looking for an exception and it's not
the rule but it's a phenomenon that does
take place and it's just countless but
it's irrelevant to the fact that the
point we're trying to make yeah so does
the solar eclipse the point is
no but the whole point is that women
don't have consequences for their
actions because the majority of women or
the majority of men can't do that it's a
very small percentage but the majority
of women can't i know if i was homeless
tomorrow i could go marry a 60 year old
i'd be chilling mm-hmm like and i and i
just think i'm like a normal girl so
most girls can do that yeah i agree with
you so like the point is women get
bailed out if we make bad decisions men
end up on the streets yeah even for men
that try hard i think it's only 20 to 30
of men are actually sexually active yeah
so there's a whole other
demographic of men that don't even get
afforded the chance to have sexual
intercourse and that's the rate of women
that are sexually um i think it's 90
percent
100 no matter what you look like
if you were if you were in the dating
market would it be hard to find someone
to sleep with you
no okay
you're dating right are you single
you're single okay would do you think
it's hard to find a guy to sleep with
you
no yeah i would think yeah
okay so you think for most what did you
say i'll make this point so the most
attractive man
could still go into a club and come out
of no one but one of the most least
attractive women could go to the club
and still come up with someone to sleep
with and she'll come out with attractive
women that have exactly that same rate
and they would be like i'm attracted
most people find me attractive i can't
get a man that she wants yeah let's say
you go
she can't get a man that she wants
a man who's going to sleep with anyone
no i'm saying that he he can go into a
club and still walk out empty-handed
even if he tries to graft on girls
but also to add to that with anyone now
but also to add to that with men yo it's
different our standards are different
for what we will sleep with here
compared to what we will be in a
relationship with like there's a lot of
girls that have had sex with guys that
are well out of their league because my
man just wanted to bust a knot with a
woman it's not like that dude i mean a
lot of women have to respect something
about you or rate something about you to
sleep with you my man could just be like
you know what she had a fat back bro
and leading on to that that's where some
women get [ __ ] up because they start
sleeping with their say a five and they
start sleeping with a ten and if that's
what level my levels are
but if he doesn't actually want to be in
a relationship with you my love that's
not your level that's it
but the whole the whole point is like as
a girl like we can just go down in looks
right like so if a girl's a six say she
can go down to get get a rich three
that's 25 years older be bailed out of
any bad decision she's ever made it's
not it's not that hard but i think there
are men that can no no but i'm saying
i'm saying what percent of men do you
really think can do that
i i don't know what the percentage if
you don't get all men that could do that
but we would agree would you agree it's
a very small percentage less than five
percent no it's not that you think it's
higher so why would you say it's better
than that all women that are making good
money so so then their ratio of being
able to get a woman who is making good
money and they can live off her
goes up every year the more women that
i'm making so why would you say it's
higher than that when dating app data so
these are two separate studies right
they surveyed women and asked them what
men they found attractive and they said
less than nine less than 20 percent of
men they found attractive and on dating
apps when women swiped right they found
less than 20 of men attractive because
okay yeah go ahead okay so when you're
swiping or the evidence is placed in
front of you
you're going to be way more in your this
is what i'm after now when you're face
to face with somebody and you're hearing
their baritones and you're feeling their
pheromones and they're in front of your
face that will probably drop a little
bit more okay depending on if you're
ovulating if you're horny if they're
ready to go things change so data when
you're swiping on faces is very one way
i i agree with you so i i do think like
there are things that men can do right
they can be funny they can you know
they're like
you're right but i they improve their
odds but i would still say it's a
minority even if let's say we double it
let's give men 40 that's still that's
still what percent could actively live
off of a girl
a small percentage even if we said 40 of
men could get a check right
what percent what percent are good
looking and have enough game to live off
of a chat i agree or even live off long
term yeah some women might take it for a
year or two
until they're like you know what not
whilst a man will a man will take a man
will happily marry a woman who works at
mcdonald's and you can stay working but
don't rest your life and it's not going
to trouble him one little bit yeah but
it couldn't work a little bit you're
trying to say that you don't know
anybody
any woman that's what the point i'm not
talking about
every time
again the exception to the rule doesn't
make the rule and that's that's what we
need to hammer home here you keep
talking and exceptions they're not
exceptional
because you're saying
you just said you don't know anybody
that are funding their whole household
and there is a man yeah but also okay so
so you know what data also doesn't match
up with what you're saying what percent
of women make that much money the
average woman and the us and i know it's
similar here makes 35 000 a year that's
not enough to take care of a dude it's
not 35k that's the average that means
half of women make less than that so
it's a small percentage of women that
can even take care of a guy and then
also it depends on the woman's
circumstances as well it depends on her
circumstances because but if you're a
single mom and you've got two youths
yeah and you've got a guy here that's a
bum yeah but he's giving you the wood
yeah but you might settle for that and
let me stay in the house because your
options ain't really there
if you're young but if you're young and
you're good looking and you're making
money you're not tolerating that so what
i'm saying is yeah that guy even yeah my
man's just she's just taking whatever
she can get because her options are just
not for that time for the time being and
then if another guy comes along that's
got more money than him she's gone
brother like that's because that's how
they that's how they're wired they're
always looking for the next best thing
and that's okay
do you know what i'm saying that comes
to the fallacy of choice because you get
so much choice you think oh it's fine
i'll get someone better and then you
keep saying i'll get someone better
until you get to that point where you
know she's a single mom with two kids
and no money so she has to settle for
that guy
i often say a woman's dating career
follows the life of say like a
footballer like when you're 16 17 you
get a couple young g's like ronaldo
they're shelling it getting getting
better and better and better then they
hit their late 20s 30s and then suddenly
you don't get offered a new contract
that a top top club and then you start
scrambling it was almost like that for
women on a date at marketing and you're
in turkey
well this is what happens and then you
start trying to revive by doing bbl's
really you're at the end of your career
and you should have just made the best
of the clubs that you're at when you had
the chance mm-hmm
okay i'm gonna read some super quick i
like that analogy i think it's yeah i
think it can go both ways but yes that's
it of course it can
how could it go
but
football thing is very good
we can we can come back to this i'm
going to read some super chats okay okay
guys so if you want to see what ish
looks like on the send money because
we're trying to get him a camera
[Laughter]
they're getting excited
okay um so black wolf ink why do modern
women need to be right instead of being
corrupt would rather love would love an
answer from the guests in the corner um
janova and and tina lady on the right
gave herself up she said equity
neets
said it best
taran tulas are yay unto me and secretly
revengeful ones christopher um serdak
whataboutism is a mental disease
sentience equity f that so
equity f that so someone who has not
worked as hard as i can get the same
outcome that's communism not only is
that delusional but if everyone was
guaranteed equal outcomes what
encourages people to improve if your
effort is wasted um nova can you explain
cognitive dissonance to the girl in the
corner please ps the hidden beauty needs
a chance to speak on the couch boy type
this woman's delusional equal rights
equal lapse home kicks a ma'am in the
corner what is your
what is your height weight and dress
size thomas carter i am i am paying i am
paying just to say that i will never
watch these if a woman in the corner is
on again she is just ridiculous and full
of double standards this is going
nowhere corey um the woman this woman is
exactly what's wrong with society in
general but especially with the black
community stop using our race to cover
your garbage arguments and she's being
racist ambi no welcome bae um no no
message thank you appreciate that um
neomosis how tall are you how much do
you weigh sounds like equality to me um
red devil studio rants how how long do
you give until 10
hag at united yes football ignore that
but i big up you look no i know my
followers are in here northwest
northwest pearl the lady next to pearl
needs to call down before frank castle
shows up
please quit talking over people it ruins
the quality of the show shadow monk
returns women purposely choose the wrong
man and then settle for the men they
don't want men should go mgtow and not
participate in relationships anymore
toxic lord yo rants what up g big love
from um seattle washington sentience men
with money won't care about how it's
spent that is the stupidest thing i've
heard from the weak men if your woman
spends money for abuse frivolously she
is a liability and she isn't supporting
him and his vision pick better sentience
women always demand men to be above them
as well as men it should be via constant
improvement and if
if she questions his frame even once he
lost consistency in her respects gents
lead via
dictatorship um shadow monk returns men
do not get married it's not worth it
mgtow is the most logical thing a man
shampoo do go your go your own way stack
your bread and live a peaceful life
sentience financial situations do not
matter woman's tolerance for inaptitude
from a man in any form is very low if
she feels like she's as good or better
than her man she will leave him which is
reflected in dispersed stats um janus
por pergo as long as women live on this
planet we always find something to
complain about or have excuses um the
savvy ninja your family is not going to
be there when you are 70 years old oh
wait that's right that's awesome
was there any that came in while i was
reading i'm just gonna have a check i'm
just gonna refresh the page and see
um okay yeah there was arthur jr um the
lady in the black is killing me she
doesn't understand exceptions mr fisher
great job with this topic pearl but the
guest in the corner is so delusional and
the perfect example of this topic
um okay that's all of them
okay
so there we go
the
let me see
do you guys think that
there should be child support
like do you
if it was up to you would you make child
support illegal or do you think it has
its place um just go around and just say
as in for both parties like just as a
institution yeah as an institution you
should be able to blame children yeah
yes yes it depends it depends so in some
situations yes some situations yes so is
it legal or illegal i don't know well
child support is legal now
um and i'm asking do you think it should
be yeah it should be legal um
it depends on it so i'm gonna wait and
hear it okay
yes but it needs to be the way it needs
to be calculated needs to be fair like
if she can't she's not if she's earning
a lot of money then
there needs to be some adjustment for
that okay
i say
yes but
it's controversial you know i was just
thinking though because if they've got
equal custody of the child then no
because when the use with me i'll pay
when it's with you you'll pay and that's
it in it that would just make sense
but if i'm paying you money and then i'm
taking my child and spending more money
when i have my child then to me it don't
really make sense in it like i come from
a home where my dad paid for everything
like even my mom and dad weren't
together and they didn't live in the
same house my dad always bought my
school uniform bought my shoes he bought
everything so
really and truly if he never paid child
support or whatever you wouldn't need to
because he bought everything what about
if there's a large disparity of income
where
one parent affording a child a lifestyle
of a private school certain luxuries and
then the other parent can't keep up with
that and then you find that
that pair that kid is now
feeling just hiding away i think that
dad would still be paying for the
private school though no no no sorry i'm
saying when he's with the dad the
lifestyle they're living is
different to when he's with him why does
he have to fund her lifestyle yeah
because the separation the it's the
challenge to figure out how to work it
out
yeah
you could see as opportunity rich dad
poor dad in real life
i don't see the need for child support
to be honest in like most cases go on
elaborate yeah because i don't
understand you can't get a job the [ __ ]
why do you need his money 100 like what
what what on earth why are you entitled
to a man's money i think in the modern
day if you're especially if you chose to
leave like most of the time women leave
why do you deserve this money you're
gonna you're gonna you're gonna leave
and then robbed man yeah
it's true if you knew you couldn't get
my money would you have left
that's what you have to ask them would
you would have stayed that's why i might
say it's cheaper to keep her in there
but it goes back to it goes back to no
consequence so i can marry a man
and leave him so make a poor decision
for the family and take half his [ __ ]
with the [ __ ] i guess we're thinking
selflessly here because um
we should you we should be thinking
about the child's interest in here not
the actual not because if we if we're
like okay you need to get a job don't
get his money but the child isn't
affected in that so it's not the it's
not the woman
maybe she should think about that before
she leaves him that's not i'm not i'm
not i'm not favoring any one of them
yeah i'm just talking about the child
because he the child is affected yeah so
so to me if you took away child support
it would take away the incentive for
women to leave because now they're
rewarded for leaving mm-hmm so the
incentive to have kids but but that
depends on each case though because some
cases the guy leaves
twenty percent
i wouldn't say i'm i wouldn't go through
proportions i could i wouldn't go
through data i'm just talking about
different societies right and but what
i'm saying is that i don't think he
should just leave for no reason too i
think people are really not careful
nowadays when it comes to
the money's solely being used for the
child
you don't and that's a lot of the reason
why a lot of men don't want to pay the
money bro because they're like hold on
like i'm gonna pay a nine grand a month
child support it's like yo what kind of
food you eating is
but that's your child at the end of the
day like it's your child you wouldn't
ask another man to pay for the child
right so so you should get a job and try
to take care of her of course no no i'm
not not favoring any one of them i'm
just saying that because the child is
affected here we should be thinking
about what's better for the child yeah
if she is earning more than him i
wouldn't say that the guy should give
child support i would say she should be
doing that she should be taking care of
them i'm not talking i'm not favoring
any of any one of them and i know it's
wrong to ask men for child support if
she has if she left or if she has done
it by herself
and vice versa if she left if he left
she shouldn't be like taking full
responsibility of the child because it
was his mistake too you know it's just
like a matter of accountability as you
said it's it's that don't you think it's
accountability for choosing the right
partner exactly oh definitely right so
so what i'm saying is if you take away
child supports peop child support people
have to face the consequences for their
actions immediately so if you're going
to pick a reckless husband that's going
to leave you for a younger model in 10
years you'll face the consequence 100 if
you're gonna leave him and take half
like you can't take half anymore so if
you want to leave you have to really
think about it and to me to me this
would put the child's best interests at
heart because there are more
consequences for leaving
and and a child is at risk if there's
one parent in the home that's why i'm
saying that we're thinking selflessly
here like selfishly here because we
don't think about the child we're
thinking about individual interests well
i'm thinking about the child because it
like from in my point of view if you
take away child support more families
would stay together because there's less
of an incentive to leave and you're
going to have less women trying to catch
a check by getting a baby off of the man
i believe if a person is selfish it's
regardless though even if it's a man or
a woman
when you say do you think women would
steal condoms from drake
no i'm serious like like because
remember when we see celebrities that's
the extreme but that means in society
women are doing this just at a smaller
rate so there are girls trying to catch
kids from rich guys all the time
because they know about child support
yeah i know i know that of course there
are people who would use that for their
own advantage i'm just saying here if if
we actually think about child's interest
then there should be child support
because they're the only ones affected
here so how how does that benefit the
child when you don't know if the mother
is going to spend it on the child yeah
of course that's what i'm saying it's
not it's it's still selfish because if
she's asking for child support and we're
not even seeing what the financial
status it's selfish itself it's it's
unfair on the guy because we're asking
for something extra from him right
it should be equal it's somehow because
if she is earning more than him she
should be taking care of the child and
vice versa so if it's 50 50 custody why
is she entitled to his money if he makes
more yeah fair enough yeah exactly
i'm always going to say that this is
what's going to happen it should have
measures in place so that we know the
money's been spent on the child yeah
yeah exactly there should be marriage so
it's not it's the fault is not on the
consequences the fault is maybe we need
to keep a check on that it is because if
there were consequences to it you
wouldn't do it so if not i thought but
we know we know the consequences
couldn't the man just spend the money on
the child and not get
i can only talk from my community a lot
of men won't do that yeah i'm talking
i'm talking about my dad my dad paid for
everything but i'm sure grown up in the
block you know a bag of man that don't
know their dad
yeah
that's different if you don't know your
dad in it but i'm saying yeah like
there's men that are involved
want to see their kids ain't allowed to
see that but this one depends
women are taking money from them and
telling them they can't see their kids
behavior does this incentivize this
incentivizes women to pick bad men and
know that even even if they're shitty
dads they can still get bailed out um
yeah because it goes back on
accountability exactly yeah but that's
what i'm saying i'm saying child support
takes away accountability from women
because even in this example right where
he has to spend it on the kid that's
saying to the woman you can pick a
shitty partner and you still get bailed
out
there's a trade there's a trader for
every consequence is really what you're
debating is
being a conservative or being someone
who's in support of a more leftist
support of the welfare state is that not
what you're debating because there's
going to be a trade-off there's going to
be a good and bad that happens to
whichever you take whichever you see as
more as the problem i'm debating
consequences yeah that's i'm talking
about consequences for women that's the
whole part of this conversation
so if a woman falls pregnant who bears
more the responsibilities of the man or
the woman
financially
in general she bears more the
responsibility of that lack of pregnancy
of what comes after
the the woman obviously she's the one
that's going to have the pregnancy so in
that so in that case if they took took
away something like child support
wouldn't that wouldn't it be a big
impetus to make a better decision on who
you fall pregnant for so far
or you have sex with what you're open
for in general because i would say as
amanda
you need to be careful with your plan
yeah sorry
so i always advocate that men need to
have discipline yeah but at the same
time
a man can just walk up and leave so
which means that regardless of whether
you want to be a principled man or not
you don't have to be you're doing that
because it's morally right yeah so but
for you as a woman
your consequences are stuck if you go
through postnatal depression your body
changes your lifestyle baby no no you
have no consequence if you don't want
one you can get an abortion yeah if you
get pregnant if you get if you
if you get pregnant now if you get
pregnant it's a choice you you made that
you made because two people had that
choice though i think i think okay okay
okay okay
you have you have you have an iud you
get an iud what percent chance do you
have of getting pregnant and don't don't
please don't bring up the exception it's
going to irritate me
you're talking about an iud
if you have an id
no no and iud is i don't want to explain
the size
okay
if you if you get a coil what percent
chance do you have of getting pregnant
obviously
yeah it's very nice less than one
percent so if you choose to sleep with
men that would be poor fathers
like that that was a choice okay so you
made that first choice and then let's
say you do that and you get pregnant
yeah you can get an abortion but i'm
talking about what about the man that
decided to have sex with a woman without
a condom does he not have any
responsibility to the child yeah it
should be illegal
what i'm saying is the women the woman
is in charge of birth
yeah so if a woman gets pregnant she
gets to decide if she gives birth if i
get pregnant with a guy and i don't want
to have the kid and he he's begging me
not to get an abortion he has no say
yes yeah so what i'm saying because of
that
women are in charge of birth yeah but
before that but the point that i was
making was that choice that they have is
not as simple as i'm just going to have
an abortion because that's their body
okay but not that but it wasn't it was
there are mental ramifications for doing
that i agree physical ramifications so
she may just be like i'm i can't do it
but what i'm saying is it's a layer of
choices so the girl could get an iud she
could also be on the list
so she could also
so she could get an iud she could also
be on the pill
she could also get a plan b
she could also require that the men she
sleeps with wear a condom yeah exactly
and
and she if and if that doesn't work out
she can get an abortion so there are
five layers that she can pick where the
men only have one and the condom can get
stolen or it can break so the women have
five layers of protection the men have
one
therefore there is more responsibility
on the women if you get pregnant that
was a choice and it wasn't just one
choice it was five choices but also
women who have a lot of girls will have
sex with a man who they know doesn't
want to be a dad and still keep their
child which is fair enough because they
know they're going to get money bro but
if you don't want to be a dad should you
not be like i'm going to wear a condom
but this is what i'm saying but this is
why you just said it was fair enough
that you just lifted but that's what i
said one of them have really hormonal
effects on a woman and a condom doesn't
so for the man to just put on a condom
you're 100 right but i know a lot of
girls that say oh i don't i don't like
that's when men wear conditioners i have
a question for the man i have a question
for the man what percentage of girls
make you wear condoms
[Music]
i make myself with okay okay but if you
know what if it wasn't up to you let's
say
a lot of women okay no let's say let's
say it was 100 up to the woman okay
what percent of women make you wear
condoms i'm gonna be real yeah most of
them like they don't say nothing to me
like i just draw for it they don't say
nothing to me they're happy to just do
whatever so they'll do whatever you say
what percent of girls
i don't even know to be honest
um
i don't know to be honest you know i
wouldn't say i don't think
[Music]
this guy's not shopping
the numbers maybe what twenty percent
twenty percent of girls
hypothetically okay what about you guys
ten
ten percent i think that's probably five
five yeah bro you know what i mean
i'd say it's about
ten percent it's about one percent
so the highest the highest percentage we
have right here is 20.
and these are these are five guys one in
five
yeah one that's not a high number so
should they not be taking accountability
for if they're going to reproduce
but the whole the whole point the whole
point is that a man can make a choice
okay he he could be super careful like
drake was and he could still get the
condom stolen i'm saying women have five
layers of choices they can make i hate
that and the point is that women don't
face consequences for bad decisions for
example they can steal the condom and
that's not illegal
yeah
yeah but yeah if you put a hole in the
condom you're going to be yeah stealth
yeah there's whole reddit threads of
girls trying to get pregnant by their
boyfriends yeah and so if we go back to
them
if we go back to the hobo sexual like
how many of
that is taking place two
you actually just looking after your
penis and putting on a condom if you do
not want okay but what if what if if she
if she pokes holes in the condom
then what but also there's certain women
that i've said to me
there's some girls that have said to me
they don't like condoms they're not like
then i would be like i am not sleeping
with you
yeah you should be taking that's a woman
talking right right
that's a woman talking about control
yeah you're guys guys and if you're
gonna be your father
no but i'm saying so if
we have five layers of account how can
you not say it's more on the women when
i just listed five layers of
accountability the man can do one it
could break right and then he has no
control over anything yeah and then it
would happen to the woman right but i'm
saying it's how can you not say it's
more on the women when i just listed
five different ways i didn't i didn't go
into [ __ ] i said it's both people have
a responsibility when you're having sex
that after this if a pregnancy occurs
and a baby comes along that you are
accountable for bringing up that child i
would say i would say it's like eighty
ninety percent on the woman because she
has five layers of accountability the
dude has one the weight and
we control we control access to sex men
control access to relationships
we we get to pick who who goes inside of
us so if you're not picking good men
like i don't feel bad for you if you end
up a single mom but then that could be
the same for the guy though so if you're
left with a baby mother that is now
taking all of your money should you not
have been accountable for not buttons
i do feel bad for them because i don't
think that's fair i think you should
face the consequences of your actions
most men want to take care of their kids
but also the problem with with your
stance is the fact that even if i want
the child i can't keep it if i don't
want it i can't opt out of paying for it
yeah and so either way you lose because
the child was because
because the equal level of
accountability would be if women control
access to sex it'd be like if you get
pregnant it's your fault the equal
accountability for a man would be if you
pick the wrong woman and she does the
madness you have to take accountability
that you picked the wrong one and many
people do like ah vanessa [ __ ] and then
oh can i say that on here
finessing [ __ ] take the bag and then
run off yeah women are celebrated for
doing that done
big facts that's what i'm saying you
think women are celebrating i don't know
i don't think about c goes up but here's
the thing i don't think it's equal
because men face consequences women
don't
they don't because the consequences
would be having to raise their child on
your own but most of the time they're
getting financial help and that's what
she's saying they're still like my man
said about the glass ceiling and then um
you know the cushion bro they've always
got a cushion that i'm saying the same
way they're not out on the street
sleeping here like they're not there not
getting no money they'll get money from
the state or they get money for the dad
or both
you know like that their time okay
sorry time energy put into raising the
child you're going on like raising
he said there was no ramifications for
that but now you're saying that you get
old like i have to put on my time and
they get custody and they also get
custody which is another point where
they're not held accountable
people have ramifications for the act
except for more weight
so you're saying that the financial
strain on a man is more so one woman
bringing us another human being because
it's not just you bringing up the human
being you're taking his finances for
your own finances yeah and his kid and
his kid and his kid because he doesn't
get custody the majority of the time
there are men who have committed suicide
because they're so frustrated with the
justice system because it's not mostly
that no eighty percent of the time the
woman gets custody no no there is more
they still have access to their children
it's not most of the time
i've had this is common
i've had multiple men come on this
podcast and on the show where they said
the mother of my child wouldn't let me
see my child for the first year after we
broke up because she was being spiteful
100 percent that's that's
what's happening
that's happened to someone close to me
bro he has to email his baby mom to see
his daughter you know email you know
what i'm saying and women don't face
consequences for doing that i think if
you're if you're keeping your kid from
the father of his of their children and
he's not abusive there's nothing wrong
with it like no i agree they're not in
danger you should face jail time because
you're putting your kid at risk
i don't know about jail time but i agree
with you there was a woman in america
took her son up to japan for two years
the dad didn't see him then she comes
back to america files a divorce and he
still has to pay child support and
because he hasn't spent time with the
child for two years he now has to pay
the full the forward in the time that
she was away and and there's a there's a
guy a kid who was 15. he got pregnant by
a 35 year old when he turned 18 you need
to pay child support
wow
hey it's imaginable
i think even sarah garvey he's his baby
mom made him pay to see his kid one time
yeah that's part of his story yeah and
he's still not that easy it's all hectic
sometimes
it's not like i don't have family
members
but then there's also the other side
there's lots of people who are
effectively co-parenting and the money
that they're getting in is very small
and it isn't enough to actually bring up
a child there's that too
that's probably because between the two
of them they ain't got money but then
boy if you're broke now i have kids but
i think also when you when you the
initial question was about you know if
i'm start earning a lot of money
speaking about if i start earning a lot
of money should um how much i'm paying
be increased because of it so let's say
if i'm if i'm a millionaire and she's on
100 000 something
should i start paying more because of it
i don't think that should be the case no
i think it should be on the individual
parent the father or the mother
i am going to contribute to my child
because i want the best for them
what if i'm still paying for school fees
but then i still have to pay for um the
50 to the woman
if they're married
they're two different things there
you're talking about alimony and you're
talking about child support they're very
different true so i i don't agree with
alimony in any way shape or form if you
get into a relationship with somebody
and you two separate it should be that
if the person was earning more than you
men or women you go your separate race
because the relationship is done child
support is about rearing the child
that's very different you should have an
obligation because you want your child
if it's about rearing the child why do
the majority of the fees go to the state
full for child support when they go to
court they make money off of it
i i don't know that in the uk i'm not
sure i don't think that's happened
actually i i don't know about you in the
uk that doesn't happen this means
testing are you sure usually it's not a
lot of money you have to look up on your
ipad but the whole thing's mad
everyone's talking about what's best for
the child what's best for the child you
keep you keep your ass in the house and
you stay together like yeah you know
what i'm saying
because the point is yeah if you're
talking about what's best for the child
yeah if 80 percent of women are leaving
just stay in it like you hear this
argument with a lot of women now these
days saying oh yeah like
our grandparents yeah they stayed in the
house and they weren't happy and that
yeah but you had a better upbringing
because you had two parents in the house
you had two incomes do you know i mean
even if grandad was out there doing the
mad thing like you still got you still
have food on your plate because they
realized the grass wasn't always green
on the other that's right
sometimes how do you know that well the
women were more accountable but no it's
not it's not the women faced
consequences exactly because they didn't
they couldn't fall back on what they can
feel back on now that's when you see the
divorce rate increase when there's no
fault divorce
like women women faced consequences back
then it's like what we were saying
before about shame you know if you're
saying
it's not what you're saying before about
shame if you're ashamed for certain
things you won't do it or you might
change your behavior because of it but
because if someone's you're somewhat
incentified incentive incentivized to
leave you will yeah i i would say that
that could happen for
in marriages with husbands as well
because to be divorced isn't such a bad
thing on either on either side kidding
there's divorce parties women i'm
talking about for men there isn't the
consequences
when we're talking about shame okay to
actually like be divorced okay on both
sides the consequences are oh i'm
divorced and then you carry on yeah my
social stigma i'm not talking about
money this i'm talking about your social
media
sorry i thought you were talking about
consequences no there isn't the social
stigma that's being divorced for either
side so both parties can go on to be in
other relationships you're taking what
i'm talking about no what i'm saying is
to stay together is optimum but if you
don't have the social stigmas
that's why there are more divorces
why there wasn't before was because
socially you would become a pariah if
you're a woman you wouldn't be able to
get married again we don't have all of
that happening now that's why it's on
the rise it's not necessarily that it's
just on women it's also for men are you
performing
the way that you should be so that the
marriage actually carries on if both
people in the marriage are not at an
equilibrium that this is working why
should a woman just stay in there
with the single parent
when you look at the single parent to
gel pipeline is very real so now you're
not having these people stay together
when you look at 75 of the people that
end up in jail they come from single
parent households so the facts are there
to see that is very significant so
should both people not be penalized for
working on their relationships or should
it just be women for the money it's just
men because we've got to pay no it
should be it should be the person that
should be penalized is the one who
chooses to leave which is mostly women
yeah i think both people if it wasn't
working uh-huh should literally be like
we have to make you love to ignore the
facts you know like just literally
ignore the facts right yeah like i know
what you're saying yeah but the fact of
the matter is yeah the reason why more
women are leaving now is because women
have more money now than they've ever
had that's the only reason why they're
leaving so
if they knew they wasn't getting that
money from him on the divorce and they
weren't getting the child support they
weren't leaving i'm telling you you're
staying your solution is that women
should earn less
no that's not my solution okay okay no
no no what i'm saying
he's saying that there is an incentive
for women to leave because they get
money women women have they own
two-thirds of debt
women women aren't in great financial
places but they get to be when they get
taken out that they all no no i'm saying
they get to be in great financial places
when they're getting a check from a dude
for the rest for 18 years
they've got their relationship in a
better state the richest the richest
women the richest women in the world got
their money through divorce but they're
the richest women in the world because
they weren't the richest beforehand they
became because they were aligned with
the richest man and then they took his
money
before you're married to me you didn't
have my assets and then when you're
leaving you have to half of my assets
now yeah so you're in a better position
so it's like so the woman gets a prize
basically for leaving
she gets free money every month and you
also have to bear in mind if you look at
the the changes between the sexes men
have mostly stayed the same yeah it's
women that have changed your mind your
mentality has changed obviously your
financial well-being has changed
a lot of the things that make you a
woman has changed so you're the ones
that are driving this
this disparity between men i i i
absolutely agree with that but what i
would say is because the times are
moving men need to actually adjust to
this
[Laughter]
50 of women over 30 are single and
childless you see that we're adjusting
women women are getting married at later
and later ages than ever so in the in
the u.s the average age of first
marriage for a woman is um either 27 or
28 in the uk it's 31. yeah so men are
marrying women
so
we have all of these stats for women
right men are also very disgruntled
they're feeling very alone but still
angry not alone i'm saying that
that's marriage easier women open more
than ever not but i say this but men are
also
true
what'd you say but i said you said that
a lot of men are disgruntled but really
yo this is probably the easiest time
it's ever been as a man to get sick
small percentage i know what you mean
but i mean in general no one out of
three men are virgins or haven't had sex
in a year and i understand that but i'm
saying they got a better chance now than
they've ever had people because women
are now open yeah no that's not you're
not correct you're not you're that's
cool but what i'm saying is the stigma
here for sleeping around here with women
yeah it's not there now like it was
before that's what i'm saying i'm not
saying that man are still i'm not saying
men are getting what i'm saying yeah
that it will be easier now yeah you've
got more of a chance now than you did no
when you needed a virgin wife you ain't
finding no virgin wife now mostly no but
i'm saying that's not correct like one
out of three men under 30 are virgins or
haven't had sex i'm talking about women
wife less
less men are having sex than ever it's
not easier to bust open the cheeks for
most men it's for for the 20 of men
yeah it's easier than ever they have
their pick okay what like for example if
you're if you're over six foot as a guy
you're in the top 15 percent of men
height wise
okay i think where we're getting
confused is what i'm saying is obviously
before as a man it was easier in the
sense here that like more women were
settling down with average men so your
average guy was getting more play that's
what i'm saying but i'm talking about in
terms of the stigma in terms of sex
women sleeping around here there's not
the stigma there no more before they're
like oh i need a nice virgin wife and
that now
man or wife in holes well you know i
mean they weren't doing that before they
had to make sure that your thing was
intact before man was thinking about
marrying you and now you know i'm saying
man running around wiping boris bites
well that's that's where it goes back to
there's no consequence yeah take away we
give birth control women can sleep with
whoever there's no consequence that's it
and then on top of that even if they get
pregnant there's no consequence they can
have an abortion and they don't know who
the daddy's mandem are raising kids
even if they get married and they they
leave there's no consequence they get
alimony or child even if they have a kid
with the wrong guy what do they get
child support even if there's homeless
there's women's shelters the point is
that women face no consequences there's
always a cushion for men they're on the
streets or they commit suicide but there
is a consequence because you are there
bringing up a child there is a
consequence for leaving your time is
spent now rearing another human being
it's not like you were running like you
just left and then you were getting
money no you're a mother but you would
have had to do that
yes yeah
but it's easier
you forced me to leave yeah or you you
leave and you force me to be worthless
divorced and i have to pay you on top of
that and then i can't see my child when
i want to see my child
as well do you know what i'm saying this
is not always the cases it's mostly the
case 80 of the time i heard you say it
was easier i heard you say it was easier
to to do it with a co-parent as such
right in a pair
she can just find another partner
that easy
as a single parent
to find another maybe not one
maybe not one that you want but to find
another man yes so again guys you guys
are saying that women should settle yeah
they should settle for what they don't
want they should be earning less money
so that they are more dependent on men
we didn't say that no no you shouldn't
be rewarded for that if yeah i said i
said it because
my whole point is that if you have bad
behavior as a woman there should be
consequences and as a society we take
them away from women okay so if i'm the
sole truck if i'm the if i'm the primary
carer for the child or the children in
our relationship and we are not working
we have a toxic environment we're
arguing all the time we can't settle our
differences and i've decided i can't do
this i don't think it's okay and i'm
gonna go for a divorce and we get
divorced and we separate when you're
selfish
and so yeah
i'm taking the children away because i
don't want them to be in a toxic
relationship that environment
and the dad shouldn't pay towards them
in any way no you chose to leave it's
selfish you broke up your home because
you're not happy and because you feel
you instead of figuring out how to work
it out you're going to leave break the
home put your kid at every statistic but
put your kid at every statistical
disadvantage because you can't figure
out how to work it out you could also
that's self-esteem you could also give
me that customer if he's a if he's a
better parent if he's impossible
we see that you know single dads raise
children better than
women so statistically he would be the
better parent if he's equipped to do it
yeah there are loads
women inherently better i i agree with
you on that i think but there are also
lots of men that don't want to take on
the primary care of responsibility and i
think because it generally falls onto
the woman
to do that i don't understand why
there would be men that would be like
i'm not going to add the lawsuit the law
set up for that the law set up to give
the woman
um the win when it comes to the child
custody
yeah
you if the father is contesting it
yeah
once it goes to that yes that is
definitely true but even if there's
loads of men that don't even want to to
do joint custody
if a man's getting married chances are
he wants to have children
and so the idea that he wouldn't want to
take care of those children i think it's
just false because a lot of men actually
complain that they don't they don't have
a proper relationship with you because
they were working yeah i think so
that's a great point you know i think
your argument was saying him being the
primary carer yeah then yes but in terms
of co-parenting i think most men that
get married and have kids would like to
co-parent 50 50. yeah the people you're
talking about are they actually married
are they just people that ended up
getting getting pregnant by some guy
that she was sleeping with and now all
of a sudden i didn't add in that no but
i'm saying that's important because what
they said is if a man gets married most
of the time because he wants kids
because if you don't want children as a
man there's no point getting married why
the hell would you do that i think it's
the main point
if i get married it will solely be
for my fam for my children it won't be
for no one else
because it won't be for the woman it
won't be for me
but when but if that doesn't work out
and you separate from the person
would you not want to be involved and
actually financially providing for your
child yeah just like my dad did my dad
weren't paying child support he bought
everything for me my school uniform if i
needed football boots he paid for that
if i needed anything and then he would
give me money every weekend to give my
mom to buy the food shopping my dad paid
for everything but like i didn't have to
go through the courts and talk about you
have to pay this amount in that mind if
i needed anything you paid for it and
i'll do the same thing for my child but
i'm not giving you money to go out with
your bedrooms and and twerk bravo i'm
not doing it if i'm finally financially
reliable for the child there are certain
rights they should be given that woman
you should be held if i'm financially
reliable for a child there are certain
um
things that should be given to me by the
law so i should have a certain amount of
hours to see that child if i'm paying
for him but that's not happening because
if women have if a woman has custody she
can say no you're not seeing it i i
agree with you so my question is how are
men not held accountable in this
situation exactly the point that he made
out that i'm not going to give her money
to go out to work in on the weekend if
you have a child with the woman that is
going to be the one that's going out to
work in take accountability that you put
your willie in the wrong place okay okay
so he does he is he is held
accountable because now he does have a
consequence
so well what is the woman's consequence
she has to be a mother and bring up the
child no but she gets free money wait
hold a minute she's like that's a freak
like a consequence okay bringing up a
kid for a woman because i thought
i thought women are maternal so the idea
of having a kid is something that it
should be stressful it's like a child
and little brother and also you chose to
have that child nobody just rang your
doorbell and said here you go either way
the whole point is that the women don't
have a consequence in this situation
because they get child support they get
alimony money isn't the same as the
thing is that you're bringing up the
child and andy and they get custody
you're right so and on top of that the
dude doesn't even get to see his kid as
much well he should be saying
whether you get divorced or not you're
having a child so you have to do all
those things
i'm talking about like two people just
having a child
a woman's consequence is raising a child
by herself is like saying a man's
consequence for getting divorced is
having to come home from working and he
has to make food for himself
it's not even it's not even close
because rearing a child is very
different than making a meal yeah but
it's a choice
to support himself through work and as a
consequence of him and then he's had a
child out there and he hasn't
decided to go before you guys are all
saying that men shouldn't be paying for
their kids is that what you're saying no
okay so i told you i paid for
i'm saying the man should be able to pay
for his kid but i don't think the women
is entitled to his money just because
she got a kid off of him and that
incentivizes women to have bad behavior
like stealing a condom and trying to get
a kid off and out but you're going into
that if the money is coming into the
woman's account that she is going to be
using it badly they often do
this is a common complaint i hear from
men
but how would they know
maybe what's the solution okay so the
accountability is that you should know
where your money is going but without
trying so wouldn't the man know where
the money is going if he spent it on the
kid yeah yeah
right right so
shouldn't the man be able to decide
where his money goes and should he be
able to he's going to do like the
shopping
he's going to buy the clothes he's going
to pay for the school fees whatever it
is that the money that would be going
into the women's account if he does that
there's online shopping you know just
send me the food shop send me the
reimbursement
reimbursement gang 100
100
because then you live lift your means
that way right but i'm saying why is she
entitled to child support why can't the
man just spend the money on his own
the the child support should be for the
child yeah and that should be how it is
however between the two of you you go
through your accountability that you are
going to pay for this or it's going to
go into my account and i'm paying for it
this way
there should be child support for the
child to be supported well shouldn't it
be
shouldn't it just be 50 50 50 50 custody
and then 50 50. they pay when it's in
the best case scenarios i think that is
exactly how it should be it depends it
depends depends on exactly how it should
be but even with because if you broke up
and use the higher earner the 50 50 you
might want to have an
elevator why are you entitled to a
better lifestyle no no i'm saying for
the child
i'm saying for the child say you're
saying the 50 50 when the the child with
the moment should be paid for well i
know what you're saying but then i'll
just be like you know what bro mommy's
broke fam that's life
wait when you're here it's it's live in
it when you go home it's beans on toast
yeah that's it this is what it is he's
going to want to stay with me
that's not a benefit
but that doesn't matter the benefit
would have been her not leaving in the
first place but now you've left but
you're worried about what you're doing
you're punishing you're punishing the
woman no no no no no no no no no no no
i'm not punishing i'm not punishing the
child because the child can come stay
with me whenever they want i'm not
punishing the child because your mom
left me bro like it's not your fault but
you know you always got a house here you
boys if you want to stay here five days
daddy got five day money it's not like
if you're poor like you're what's wrong
with that yeah there's nothing there's
nothing wrong with that evil yeah
i'm just saying
inadvertently you may be punishing
through punishing your wife for like
saying look i'm the better parent you
may punish the child exactly and the way
he's the wise parent
but he will see his mother as less than
his father's on the scene because
no no no
okay but then she should get a job like
the men have to go get it you can work
yeah that's true because
like the woman is inherently punishing
the child by divorcing them anyway yes
if there's two wrongs
she's now in a situation where she can't
afford the same lifestyle that husband
can that's on her yeah she's not
entitled to the livestream
the poor decision are we just going to
do that
because
we can't be ignorant of the effects
that's on the kids because we all know
the statistics of what was the children
when it when the nuclear family breaks
down so we can't be
like egotistical or ignorant of the
facts of knowing the effect it's going
to happen the child so we still need to
maintain the stability of the kids
upbringing whilst doing what else needs
to be done i'm saying there should be no
incentive
to leave absolutely correct
but i'm saying with child support there
is an incentive
because that money can elevate the life
her lifestyle why why is she entitled to
his money correct me if i'm wrong but
the model we were talking about now was
if the man were to pay for even just for
the child the money let's assume that
the money is going to the child
while while the child is living with the
mom
you were saying that he shouldn't pay
but i'm saying if he is going to the
child while he's the child with the
parent there shouldn't be because you're
taking away the consequence of the
expensive cost of a child for the woman
you're again making it easier for her to
leave
she's left now so i'm trying to benefit
my child it should be already gone she's
already made that bad decision so then
if the man wants to do that he should be
freely able to if he wants he shouldn't
be legally forced yeah her bad decision
i think most men want to take care of
their kids and if it ends amicably most
guys are gonna they're gonna do what's
best for the child what i'm saying is
there shouldn't be a gun to his side
saying you have to pay your baby mama
who destroyed your home especially if he
has access most of the time when i hear
guys ain't trying to pay no money
because they can't see their kids
that's why you know what i'm saying i
don't hear man that have their kids all
the time saying i ain't giving no money
like i don't hear that so if the guy's
got the access and he's got the 50 um
custody i'm sure he won't mind handing
over the bread and also if a man's
making a lot more than a woman yeah why
is that not taken into account here when
they're doing custody in the first place
because you're talking about the
standard of living for the child if i
make four times more than
um the wife here like you can't tell me
that the kid's not gonna have a better
life at my house exactly but then i have
to pay for
nah nah and then and then she's wearing
gucci blood when she's making hm money
don't make sense they think that
inherently a woman will be able to take
care of the child better but if i'm
making more money that puts me in a
position
you're gonna have to tilt the mic into
yeah like sorry man that puts me in a
position where i can then take care of
that child better so if in that
situation if i'm in that situation i
should be giving custody but if you're
really wondering
it depends on time though and there are
lots of cases like usher he had more
money than and tamika and he had the
children the most of the time that there
are instances where when the man is
earning more and they do want the child
because they are like i am the better
parent no there's exceptions to the
precisely yes but there are also lots of
fathers who are working a lot and are
like i don't have the time to rear this
child i may have the financial capacity
and i agree that most hedge fund
managers say in your career your
successful hedge fund manager would they
want to look after a child full-time if
they were if they were separated from
their wife
they're getting that need to be honest
that's what i'm saying the child so
they're not going to be the you you'd be
like let's actually fund
the child's lifestyle so
do you know what's crazy i have men in
my dms like guys with check marks with
money status and influence that say they
have problems with child custody that's
what they send me their stories and
these are these are men with money so
what does that mean for the average i
literally just said to you i have family
members who are currently in this
situation with their baby mothers now
two two kids apiece literally because
they have moved on are not able to see
their kids but they're not the ones i'm
talking about i'm literally talking
about the ones who if the person has
gone and and filed for child support
okay in this country anyway the money
that you're gonna get is really [ __ ]
it's not actually worth it it's not like
in america it's very different you're
not going to be able to fund a lavish
lifestyle on what you're going to be
awarded because it's so calculated it's
not that great i'm saying most of the
time anything why do you
have a it's just better to have an
amicable
like reasoning
mediation somebody else comes in and you
split it and it's it's
it's custody it's 50 50 custody i think
that is the best now but you're still
leaving why you left though
but you left though you know i mean if
you still work at nando's and you left
you ain't getting free chicken normally
yeah like i said you're not talking
about alimony we're talking about child
support yeah the money should be going
to feed and close
though
if he chooses to
get he should get the choice if you if
you get left out
okay
like like he should get the choice he
shouldn't have a gun to his head saying
oh she left you and now you have to pay
for the kid but you should want to this
is fuel yeah yeah you're right he should
he probably does want to but i'm saying
the government should not make him
because if the woman if the woman's
acting if the woman's acting up and like
like not letting him see the kid or
something he should be able to take away
the money that's yeah he should be able
to but it's not right now
i think that is fair but it's no
different it's just like if you're a
child it should be just like be removed
it's just like if a woman gets pregnant
and you say they're called i don't want
to be a dad and she goes i will too bad
and she keeps to you anyway but they're
still going to run you down for bread
you know i mean and then on the flip
side if you say yo like i want the child
and she says i don't but if child's gone
then you have to live with the
consequences either way we ain't got no
saying nothing so it's one of them ones
where if you leave
i don't see why i should have to give
you any money i would want to but i
shouldn't have to because you would have
got money if you didn't leave so in this
same scenario where we don't have a say
on anything and i'm saying well you
should just wear a condom well you
should have picked better i do
wouldn't that be the same for the woman
when she'd get cheated on when you're
like if you're getting cheated on you
should take responsibility for that
because you pick back is he looking for
the consequences of being cheated on his
differences i'm saying i'm saying i'm
saying there should not he should not
have to pay
that's what i'm saying why should he not
have picked better he should have okay
yeah like he should have picked better
but my whole point is that when a man
picks wrong there's a consequence when a
woman picks wrong she takes half
well you're not getting half if you've
just had a child for somebody it's not
hard okay okay
the number isn't the point you
understand the point i'm making like the
point is that when a woman makes a bad
decision there's no consequence when the
man makes a bad decision there is well
that that's where we differ i guess
because there is a consequence it even
depends on the society though
because um what you're saying is the
woman would take half right if you go to
arab countries that's not the issue
that's not the case i know but we're not
in it but this is what girls don't
understand clearly but i'm saying
clearly in the context of this
conversation we're talking about the
west yeah of course yeah i'm just
telling you like there are a few cases
that it does not get implemented that
way right yes but it's the exception
it's not the rule yeah of course and you
can see mergers last longer then yeah
and also in those
cultures and that like man can have
multiple wires and i could do all these
things and a woman's not necessarily
going to leave you just because of that
because she understands of the family
she can but most of the time they don't
because they understand him because they
don't have any other they don't want to
go backwards
i'll take one for the team
[Laughter]
okay
this is where my head did you just say
women to vote yes yeah i said i'll take
one for the team
give the right back to vote i said give
the right back no no vote in no being
able to do this
just take their driver's licenses that's
fine i know i hate driving i don't know
why we fought
you know what i'm saying everything else
you can keep i'm just saying
maiden's tail
the hair needs to change i think she's
trying to get us there to the handmaid's
tower no i'm just trying to look at it
look at okay hear me out hear me out in
the 50s if women just waited it out okay
before we didn't have to work we got to
be housewives and now everything's
automated what we're tripping if we just
waited 20 years the washer we have a
washer and dryer we have roombas we have
dry cleaning like
if we just waited it out we would all be
chilling it's funny
we would all be chilling but where's
ambition like that i think if a woman
wants to have to be that housewife yeah
and it's just living and they're just
cooking cleaning to let
there are other women who have ambitions
who don't
we're sentient we're not literally
doormats and we're not the same and some
people want to have careers and they
want to invent things and they want to
do other stuff
and there are men i mean
i made this show like i'm very creative
and driven but i mean it's a lot easier
when you don't have the pressure of like
easier if that's where your mental is
but there are lots of people who it's
not that yeah they don't want to be they
don't want to be cooking and cleaning
well i mean i'm saying like as a
housewife i mean it doesn't mean you
don't have hobbies and like other stuff
that you can do no they may want to
actually like change the world
they tend to stay at home a lot of times
they don't tend to go back to work i
think there's a reason for that yeah
yeah yeah i don't i don't actually want
to return and also when they talk about
cooking and cleaning and that
when you go into it it's like
i think the elections yeah but you're
talking about cooking and cleaning but
listen if your husband's got money you
ain't even got a clean you can get clean
on it
it's not that deep you can get a cleaner
i mean most housewives probably have
hobbies like they go to the gym so they
get to go out shopping they get to do so
many or they're in charge of like
philanthropy like they they have
organizations that they run they get
involved in their community talking
about like side stuff i'm talking about
people who have
full-on ideas they want to invent stuff
they're scientists they are changing the
world like they are not i don't know
those women are minorities the majority
the majority of women don't invent
things
the majority of humans don't do much
yeah but
other people who do invent it tends to
be men yeah that's what i mean they
should be people who do invent it tends
to be men don't divorce your husband and
keep your kids out of prison you know
the ones that you're saving in the world
that's why you're saying okay
it's true though you might stop someone
from getting shanked just because you
didn't leave your husband like you never
know
could happen i'm gonna read some secrets
i'm gonna read some i'm gonna read some
super chats okay so um manny f is a
mother allowed to exit motherhood oh if
a mother is allowed to exit motherhood
should a father be allowed to exit
father fatherhood and not have to pay
child support um stephen o'brien if he
leaves it's different but if it's her
yeah
rosalinda lozano
five dollar super chat pp
um a hundred hundred dollar super chat
thank you so much
thank you um get a camera for ish
um for the algo
chick that is yap and needs guidance not
you pearl billy boy um that man the man
should want to take care of his child
meanwhile girls should have the choice
um christopher serdock the woman's moral
bankruptcy is astounded astonishing or
rather astonishingly astonishingly
common these days bm mackel show her
kevin and jordan asap wilfred willfully
ignorant ties purpose life coaching it
is not it's not a consequence for a
woman to bring up a child if she chooses
to ignore five precautions before
choosing to have a child remember
bringing a child up and raising a child
isn't the same thing brandon schaefer 5
super chat red devil studio dave
chappelle if you get to kill it i get to
abandon it your body your choice my
money my rules
garth went there stay-at-home moms are
directly responsible for the success of
a family women often get lost in the
lost in the fantasies of tv life and
social media 20-year married chick in
the corner you're lost get you you got a
mind of a diamond um
the
stefan pierre jerome what planet is this
world living on she uh she's allergic to
facts accountability statistics staying
on topic and probably good men she's
married i wonder what the hell her
husband's going through shadow monk
returns men all this stuff can be
avoided if you just go mgtow mgtow
equals no marriage no relationship no
cohabitation no children gentlemen wake
up
ring ringside with lcd men are the
majority majority held accountable women
make choices men don't even have shardie
in the corner keeps moving the goal post
with the most disingenuous points from
negative situations between men and
women having a child sentience to the
masculine women in the corner if dating
app stats show that 80 of women choose
the top 20 of men ask this question if
only at the top 20 percent are smashing
and potentially reproducing can you
apply
your logic about most men when most men
don't smash michael how is raising a
child a consequence if that's what she
wanted that way she had
the way she had to lie to make her point
is crazy honest citizen domestic
violence is meant to create a false
perception need for feminism so girls
are eternal victims and men are eternal
offenders no one worries about the
murder rate of men laws are never 100
never 100 stuck stop crime
christopher serdak pearl thank you for
presenting us to a prime example of a
card-carrying miss misandris this is
example of why marriage is dead still
low-key 21 jesus christ the lovely lady
on the right can hit the hill in the
head with a frying fa pan of facts and
still not getting no accountability
whatsoever damn thomas carter here is a
fact women in the corner ignores facts
and states opinions the the
less
leon sun 100 the slogan for the child is
the best the slogan best for the child
is from hitler um
fwic tv at fashion shout out to pearl
for standing up for the brothers um
the vm mackel's the emoji um lea the
leon son 100 the black community are
stagnant because of the abortion the
abortion rate is super high in every
country so stop saying women don't run
to abortion billy boy so men are
stronger thus harsher punishment is a
trans woman a woman or say if i'm a
woman does the standard change david
david um race my man likes rants you
know big up surprised to see you on this
side of youtube united are
in the mud still
still you know them ones there yeah amen
dana what what what kind of societal
construct would you like your daughter
and son to live in um jc she doesn't
understand that child support was put in
place in in the child's interest child
support is in the court's interest not
the child it's bs weldon coven do the
ladies arguing understand we're in the
chat where where we in the chat and the
panel are coming from do they understand
how one-sided the court system as as
alexander alexander ryan beware
conflating child support with alimony
child support is to help with daycare
health insurance clothing and food
silent lamont using the child as a proxy
or pawn is sinister the lianson 100
walmart is always hiring
christopher cerdec it's no longer child
support now it's hostage taking and
women's early retirement to in
retaliation funding arthur jr the lady
in the back is killing me she doesn't
understand exceptions um okay i think i
did these all let me just refresh it and
make sure there's no more hostage you
know
yeah some of those are a bit mad nice
true though the hostage thing might have
to link you you at the bus stop for five
minutes um
stop stop sean sean spencer um two
dollar super chat jonathan comp what
about sending child support to a card
that is able to show exactly what the
money was spent on to your caseworker
could help with the thieving steve
o'brien women bloated the workforce now
labor
now labor compared to what your page is
extremely low for voting too they vote
70 democrats so i'm saying i'll take one
for the team john smith um can we
um can we make big shirley watch hours
of kevin samuel's clockwork orange style
so she can develop some sense um shadow
monk returns it's illogical for any man
to get married period manny f of the
mother okay that's the oh this is a good
question if the mother is allowed to
exit motherhood should a father be
allowed to exit fatherhood
yes or no
who said that mothers are allowed to
exit so they can have an abortion
oh you in that regard yeah so if there's
an unplanned pregnancy should a man be
able to financially opt out and say like
sign off his rights
and have no consequences you say no
okay
uh if a man has no say in whether child
is born or then yes he should be able to
opt out okay
i believe both of them take the choice
before having sex so yeah
yeah i mean he can opt out of fatherhood
he he should be able to opt out of
fatherhood okay she would say yes
absolutely yeah should be able to opt
out yeah absolutely you should be able
to opt out 100
so
do you think that that a man should have
a say if a woman has an abortion or not
no i think once it's got to that stage
and you've had unprotected sex with the
person
i think that act and it turns into
an embryo you're you're beholden it's
happening
if she says it's happening it's
happening the thing is the thing is i
actually
i'm not someone who's necessarily for
abortion but the point is
you decided to have sex with a man who
didn't want to have children and so now
that you're
forcing him to have children you can't
then complain if he doesn't want to pay
for it is the point she
those are two different things to me but
the thing is
the law enforcement wanting it to happen
i think it should be law that he does
pay oh god no
what i don't think it should be do not
think that's a little bit of a double
standard that is madness the child is
here
no it wasn't though but not not if she
got into no but she's but
so i would i'm not really like pro-life
in that way i think you have your
choices but if she has decided i'm not
going to have an abortion
and the child comes about i think two
parents are then responsible for raising
the child
it's your body your choice yeah
but if i don't have a choice in that
matter like my i'm like well your choice
was no no no no i don't have a choice
let's look let's stop playing this game
no no playing this game i don't have a
choice because i do not want that kid i
chose to have sex with you i didn't
choose to have an offspring and this
year you chose to have an offspring yeah
why are you forcing me to have to pay
for it because i do not want it's not
right the same way i'm not going to tell
you
get rid of that baby and get out your
body or i can't force you to get rid of
that baby you shouldn't be able to force
me to have to pay for a child that i do
not want it's not
they know this ingenuous it's very
disingenuous to say that because
you know they don't you know they don't
because women can have sex without
having children and that we see that's
happening
rampantly but yet men don't apparently
have that same right
but it's happened so you had said that's
the point that's the point it's
happening you paid right
so i i shouldn't necessarily be
forced to pay for i think i think once
the child comes about you have to pay
but i think that would make sense if you
made it equal
so if a woman gets to opt like like she
was saying like if a woman gets the
option to opt out of motherhood
shouldn't a man have the option to opt
out of fatherhood why does only a woman
get that say
because the child is here now so so
because of the woman's choice okay so
the woman has a choice yes and she's
gone through it and the child is like
six choices i forgot about adoption
okay so
the child is now here yeah and the man
has decided i don't want to be a parent
right so then should the state
pay for that child to them no the woman
should
because she made the choice to have it
when she could have had an abortion but
then earlier on you guys went through
all of the stats of the single parent
household right how that actually leads
to the detriment of the child yes
if it was so the child should be
punished for the woman and the man's
choices she'd still be in a single
player if it was up to me it would be
equal abortion wouldn't be legal and the
man well i don't child support wouldn't
be a thing but i think it should be
equal if i think you can say to a woman
you should have an abortion and then it
takes place is what you're saying no no
i'm saying i'm saying i don't believe in
abortion i if it was up to me i wouldn't
have it but since it's legal i mean i
think like that's not going to change
any time soon it's already legal i'm
saying it should be equal so a man
should be able to financially opt out of
a child if
if a woman can opt out of being a mother
okay
it's to make it equal okay so that
and you're saying that solely then if
it's the woman that's saying i'm going
to have the child all of the financial
responsibilities should just go on her
yeah yes and the state shouldn't get
involved to help yes because she had six
options because even if she has the kids
she can still give it up for adoption
i'll give you a story my mom was 17. she
got pregnant by my dad right and instead
of they didn't have money they're in
college and they gave that kid up for
adoption and he's like 30 years he's
he's married now he has his old life
ahead of him
and so he was raised in a two-parent
household
and so i'm saying why can't she do that
okay
yeah i fundamentally don't agree with
that i think that when the child is here
that both parents should be right so i'm
saying she could find a family to do it
without your parents
it's like you give these things like
there isn't any emotional ramifications
that's that's it was a really tough
decision for my mom yeah i'm saying it
was really important to do that right
but i'm saying that's selfish
though into this but when you look at
the care system of how many people in
the uk care system go to prison it is
doing red or black that i don't think
adoption is viable
you don't have to do adoption but what
you can do is pick a better man to make
a kid with yeah i want to go on go on
birth control i'm saying there's six
layers i agree with that i'm saying she
had i'm not saying it has to be adoption
i'm saying choice choice choice choice
choice and choice so why can't a man
financially opt out of being a father
because i think all of those choices
that the woman can go through are are
not the same as the financial burden
yeah i hear that
they're very different you were talking
about the ramifications of you know
being putting a child in adoption but
again
you're not considering ramifications of
growing up knowing your dad didn't want
you
yeah that can destroy your men yeah
that's true 100
because like you're like the child's
here now but this is not amazon prime
bro it takes like nine and a half months
for the youth to come or something like
that do you know what i mean it's not
like he just turns up like that the
payment comes out and then
it doesn't don't happen so should the
man not get his head around that i'm
having a no no i'm not getting my head
around anything if i tell you like at
the time if we find out that you're
pregnant and i say yo like
you know i'm saying i'm not ready for
your dad i don't want to be a dad maybe
financially i don't think i can do it
many i'm not in the right space you told
me now we're having a baby
it's my body my choice but a man can say
yo what is my money my choice i know i'm
just like if you don't understand you
know that guy probably doesn't want to
be a dad you know that straight away
but then you are you got to still force
him to you don't even know his situation
whether he's financially stable whether
he's in the right mental state to have a
child how could how was that morally
right though
of and i'm saying
that is blanket wants a child but how is
that not really right though because
like i'm not talking about morals i'm
talking about so the moral implication
would be
your offspring is here
you said i don't know you said before
is has to be held accountable for for
taking part in having sex yeah
morally he should be there to look after
his kid as someone who participated in
them in creation of this child yeah so
how can you then morally say that oh my
morals are correct in saying i'm going
to force this man to have to be a father
that doesn't want to be a father
how is one because the child the child
is going to be here now and i think as a
man
and you have your child what about you
i would not do that but for other women
if i'm going to advocate for other women
in that position
they may have all of their their
emotional isms as to why
it may be it may be a moral issue for
them they're like i can't have an
abortion this is my child i have to go
through with this this is where we are
i think as a man if your offspring is
here you should pay for that child i
understand what you're saying because
i'm not necessarily i don't necessarily
agree with abortion i'm just saying to
you the moment you decide to disregard
all the six different um options you
have and say you're having this child
i should be able to say well that's fine
but i'm not gonna do that all the time
you can also i'm talking about from my
point of view legally you should pay but
i don't what do you mean mindy dollars
on that they don't pay for their kids
but it's not it's not right
to force me to lose and i think the law
is correct in this instance
i'm saying there's a difference between
more like if if my brother got a girl
pregnant i i think he should take care
of the kid morally but i think there's a
difference between that i'm putting a
gun to a guy's head and saying you must
take you must pay for the child well
nobody has a gun to their head well i
mean sort of legally you can go to jail
for not paying child support even if you
actually don't have the money to pay you
can still present but yeah not over here
you can't okay
you cut you know that's still in the
west you know in the western world yes
but no but you only will go to prison if
you do have the means and you haven't
paid no even if you don't have means you
will still
in america yeah in america so over here
i i have numerous friends they have not
received a penny from their baby fathers
they have decided that that they're not
going to pay i think that you should pay
yeah and you should want to pay as a man
the whole the whole point is that
legally like i don't think legally i
think sorry if women legally have the
choice to not be a mother i think men
should legally have the choice not to be
a father i disagree i don't i don't
really agree with women not being able
to i don't really agree with women not
women having the choice to not be a
mother but i'm just saying if they're
going to do that it should be equal yeah
i disagree do you think it's conducive
for men if that was the implication that
men didn't have any legal
they had the legal right to sign off
right don't you think men would just be
[ __ ] everything that walked with
reckless abandonment
is that a bad thing for society it would
it would require it would require women
to be more careful with who they slept
with because there would be a
consequence the whole point of this
whole show is that women there's no
consequence
and so like women can sleep with a guy
get the kid
and then even get a beta to marry her
later
and still get the money from both guys
yeah yeah sure yeah once she gets
married then he doesn't have to pay
that's why but you've got no no you're
going on like it's a lot of money this
is the thing that's like really like
normal smile
for some for some men it is and it
doesn't matter it should be zero yeah
there shouldn't be any incentive for a
woman to break up her home or for a
woman to catch a kid from a guy who
doesn't want one
and his per child says i think it's like
200 pound per child so you have three
kids for you're going to pay 600 pounds
if you've done it three times and you
weren't really you know
i hear that i hear that i do hear that
but if you've got if you've had three
kids of her then she needs but the
marriage the marriage though she leaves
the marriage you didn't want to leave
the marriage
why should you be obligated to pay six
hundred pound that i didn't even want
but would you could you not want to your
kids to be in a good team i don't think
i think this is where we're getting it
confused it's not that men don't we're
not saying we don't want to pay we'll
say we don't want to be forced to pay
there's a difference but it's not in
every circumstance because the person
has to go to the courts but then the law
should make it case-by-case rather than
just a blanket you have to pay but it's
it's not like that that's why we're
discussing those
the mother has to file for it or you two
decide this is what you're paying and if
she files for it mortality is going to
win that's the thing and also she has
the option to file or not foul in it
yeah the man don't have the option to
not and if you dip then boy he's gotta
deal with the consequences isn't it
because i see his kids when you say he
can see them and all of that nonsense
but then you're taking his money don't
make sense well you go to a court and
try and get yeah yeah you're not gonna
win and lose well and you don't know how
long it'll take them to go to court so
they can't see the kid in the time being
it takes to get to court and like when
covid happened a lot of courts were
backed up for months
and so men there were guys that didn't
see their kids for a year
and the woman and the woman had no
consequence for that yeah like i
personally i think if you if you
have no reason to and you're not letting
the dad see the kid and you have no good
reason like honestly you should go to
jail for that i don't there should be
harsh i think that for as long as he
didn't see the kid like i think there
should be harsh consequences women
should be afraid to do that
and let's not pretend as if all men have
the finances to pay yeah because it's
really it's really not hard to not let
your the or to let your kids see their
dad like i really agree with all of that
but i think prison is very different as
a punishment for most crimes in my
opinion so for a mother because she
isn't allowing the father to see her
child and then she goes to prison who's
that serving how is that for the better
she's disadvantaged
i don't think you keep missing the point
it's not the point isn't to send her to
prison the point is to deter her from
doing stupid things yeah i agree that a
punishment should be in place
why does the punishment matter the
punishment should be something that
makes you think i do not want to have
that punishment
prison and removal of a parent from a
child has don't let him see that there
wait wait then but but she did the same
thing she did the exact that's exactly
what she did we should compound the
effects of this if we say that again we
should compound the effects of i'm not
saying we should compound the effects of
it i think a woman i'm saying no i'm
saying a woman would think twice if she
knew that every day
that she didn't let the dad see the kid
she got two days in prison i think it's
that serious i think it is that serious
if you are not letting the dad be in the
kid's life because you're putting your
kid at every statistical disadvantage
that is selfish i think that is so
selfish and if you if you choose to do
that yeah you made your bed you should
you should go to jail for that people go
to prison for stuff every day and that
doesn't stop them from doing it i think
that's it
you mean men go to prison
if you're going to prison all because
you won't let the baby dad see your
child like you you probably aren't fit
to look after your children
i agree with you and i think there are
lots of people that would die on that
sword and i don't think that's in the
betterment of children
if if a mother would go on that's all
she probably shouldn't have the kids in
the hospital
and then sometimes you've got to fight
there you you you got to put it together
and you've got to go to court but again
men don't a lot of men don't have the
finances to do that
and you know
so that's the point you can't just be
saying
wisely wear condoms a lot of men go
broke trying to get their kids back
and so they'll spend years trying like
in court fighting for their kids and
then they just give up because they're a
negative income yeah definitely
i know of that but the way you're
speaking is it is you don't care
this is the problem
i can see why she doesn't care i think
from a female's perspective right she's
looking at and going women are
hypergamous which means they're looking
for the highest valuable man they can
capture the moment that woman has got
that man and his offspring she's
achieved everything she needs to in
the game she's got the game so why is
she going to release that for anything
that anyone's talking whether it's moral
whether it's reasonable whether it's
um logical logical like she's not going
to give it up because she's clocked the
game in what she wants to do the same
way if a guy was sleeping around with
the girls that he exactly wants
why is he going to stop doing that but
you know you know what's really crazy
i decided he basically said that if you
were a world leader you do really well
because you just have to be
compassionate but just being like oh
well about these sorts of issues
because you guys are presenting me with
things where it's like this is how it is
and and as i said before i think there
is an adaptation that needs to take
place with men because i see a
dissatisfaction and you're talking about
things like it's not going to change
unless you go to the extremes of you
remove being able to vote you remove the
the way that you can make money or you
just hold women accountable for bad
behavior
you can do that okay you can do that but
i do what the answer was was prison and
i was like how is that in the betterment
for a child one example
that was pearl's
yeah so
we can go over what the accountability
is how is a man going to prison for not
paying child support for the betterment
of the child but yet you don't have an
issue with that which is the point i
absolutely was like i don't see that as
okay but then you can go jailbreak they
don't do that here but exactly but if
you go to if the woman would have the
consequence of going to jail too she
wouldn't do certain things there are
lots of things in the american judiciary
system where i'm like that doesn't make
any sense we do not do that over here
but they don't vote so that's not
something that happens or because you
can die on that sword that's cool that's
like okay i'm not done
i'm just saying to say oh it doesn't
happen it doesn't matter is it no it's
like i i do not agree with that like
we're not arguing over this i'm
literally saying i do not agree with
that that should not be the answer to
not paying child support because it's
not in the betterment for the child is
it that simple everything i've said is
the money and everything else should be
in the betterment for the child not for
either partner it's about the child
that's why it's called child support
it's very simple but would you not agree
okay let's take take america would you
not agree that if a woman if a man can
go to jail for not paying child support
would you not say it's fair for a woman
to go to jail for not allowing a man to
see his child
i don't think it's fair it's context
that the context
i don't think it's fair that anybody is
going to prison in this situation
with the context by okay men are say men
are men are going to jail would you not
say in that society if a man is going to
jail for that would it not make sense
also for a woman to go to jail not
allowing him because the answer happened
to equal rights putting people in prison
it's not
because the answer isn't anybody should
go to prison the answer is never that
but we're saying within the context that
someone does go to prison
should this be fair no
self self awareness is so important all
right my gosh so you're trying to say
that sending people to prison no
i'm saying all i'm saying is it deters
people from bad behavior
yes it does it doesn't that's what it is
when i'm angry i'll never punch a man
because i know i'll go to prison and
there's consequences and that's you and
there are other people and most people
don't do that but that's that's what i'm
saying
any law enforcement officer will tell
you that if you increase the punishment
for a crime less people do it no i
disagree with that
wait so you don't think when class like
weed went from class b to class a there
was a dip in whether people would do it
what was selling weed
either
longer sentences for people being placed
but it doesn't it doesn't go in the same
way it doesn't go in the same way
because when you look when you look at
norway here their prison system is about
rehabilitation at the lowest offense
rates when america when they did the war
on uh war on drugs they just increased
imprisonment rates they didn't and loads
of make crime go down it's exactly that
so i don't ever know but there was all
sorts of reforms you have to remember
there was a tipping point there was
other reforms that took place in places
like norway even portugal was another
example
where they did criminalize yeah they
don't apply those same so so my next
question is similar okay
we're gonna go back to jail time
do you think if so
some studies say that up to like 20 25
of men are raising a kid that's not
theirs oh [ __ ] you know yeah that much
that's [ __ ] cool man said what one in
four men are reasons someone else's
not knowingly no it's more like one and
three i think okay yeah one one and four
let's just say 20 on the low end okay
okay this is not this is 2022. if a girl
does that knowingly or knowing that
there's a chance that that kid is not
his should she face prison time for
every year that that man wasted raising
a kid that wasn't his sheikh gun show
that should be allowed at least one free
bag
one three you know just on the courts
okay yes yes or no
oh please what was it yes or no should
she face [ __ ] yeah
yeah
no
come on okay he wasted time resources
money she should waste the same let's
make it equal it's at least a fraud case
you know what i'm saying yeah
it's fraud okay
so if he got her 16 years yeah and he
was raising yeah and she had been doing
fraud it would probably be four years
it's fraud i think it goes under for
under fraud okay yes and every child
born speaking to them yes and every
child born should have a
paternity test because okay yeah i agree
yeah yeah that's a fraud and she should
go to jail a hundred percent afford she
should get a receipt
case okay fraud straight to joe you know
okay we do we agree yeah
now i want to argue no
[Laughter]
i've already like experienced
i i have experience with that and i do
think the girl should have gone to
prison yeah
she'll have to pay all that money back
as well that you spent you know wasn't
someone close to you fraud yeah yeah i
was a good friend okay and it was a long
time
what happened was very painful so she
those are the [ __ ] were you friends with
the girl other guy no the guy you're
friends with the guy and she how old was
the kid
they had got to about 11. 11.
[Music]
he ain't even the same he ain't the same
yeah
a couple men would jump off mm-hmm
how did he find out came clean she came
clean eleven you know yeah and all in
high school
it's about the man
it's everybody else and it's it's
everybody around because they they are
kids that you all love as well so it's
the grandparents it's auntie uncles it's
everybody involved what would make them
come clean after 11 years though like
what happened i think it was conscious
wow
you mean he lasted that long and then
all of a sudden the conscience kicked in
11 years a long time people were
different
i find it interesting that when this is
something this is a topic that you know
it's affected you personally since you
know someone you
you're more so on our side but yeah on
the other ones and this is still this is
still a situation where we're saying the
woman should go to prison so the mum
wouldn't be in a child's life for a
certain period of time but yeah with the
other topic
of the damage that was caused was so
much and the other side of it is
monetary i don't place it the same if
the child is more likely to end up in
prison or
from being a single-parent household
even with um also called even with him
paying child support
that's still damage right
like what do you say so when it comes to
having having the man's child who
doesn't want the child
right
she's that child isn't a single parent
household he's still more likely to go
to prison even if he's paying child
support
yeah and i don't agree with that yeah
but the point is you know
we're just saying
a man shouldn't have to
pay for it if he doesn't want to but i
understand what you're saying what i'm
saying
the deception in this instance
had such ramifications on so many
different people's lives
that she should do time for fraud
if we can send people to prison for
flipping spending on credit cards
fraudulently mm-hmm
what she did affected loads of people
she should go to prison but even if
someone's not a man one person can still
go to prison for last time
are we
i said it's not okay he's trying to
ascertain why you agree with this or not
the other one is because you feel
personally no um attached to this
situation because you know someone has
happened to you because i know the
people that it's affected but that's
what i'm saying that's the point
at the point that when we went around
the room she did agree with everything
we said for this specific type of i
don't know i know
but that was before we found out there
was a personal and no but that's what
i'm asking is it because of the personal
attachment 100 percent and it always
knows because the other stuff doesn't
affect her it's never affected us she
doesn't know how much it is and i
clearly said earlier on as well i have
two cousins currently going through that
okay now
but
should the women in that situation go to
prison no fair enough i was trying to
ascertain why yeah they shouldn't it's
that's an emotional thing between the
two of them and i and i get the point
but this was a a deception of the
highest order i think it's it's as bad
as like
the tinder spinner that's worse it's
worse than tinder that's what i'm saying
but i'm talking about like the jail time
should be associated with this tinder
i'm just getting it back for demand
okay um
i think this was a really great show
guys i think we're gonna wrap it up um
i'm gonna do super chats one more time
and then we can go around and everyone
can do any final thoughts and where
people can find you so i'm reading these
think about what you want to say um okay
so let me refresh them
before i start reading okay
so stephen oh brian the government gets
their cut out of cs as well
perseverance
sham leon
guys to put it simply either be celibate
or use protection because it seems many
ladies are unable to use contraception
save yourselves
mad max
she makes me consider a vasectomy
the longer the conversation goes the
more the corner lady shows she doesn't
care only asks questions that have
percentages so she can't game the
questions sd
fdfds i have six former friends who
committed suicide everyone had a
girlfriend but all were all were
psychologically abused by them i want to
say most of the suicides happen men are
co-hub cohabitation sabotage and mental
abuse nah 299 thank you very much
stephen o'brien the lack of comp
compassion from the woman on the subject
of child support is carrie it's scary as
well independent thought joe rogan
brought up your viral video i know with
ali on his recent episode with colin
noor um sean spencer
thank you for the super chat stephen
o'brien i work for a law firm that
handles
family law it's unreal how many women
contact us looking for divorce and get
child support and to get child support
and how many men call in having been
completely shattered by the system mad
max uh a cherry is red herr i disagree
it has a seed me to [ __ ] does that mean
sean spencer two dollar super chat thank
you um xanax um
pearl should look into tell telomeres or
look up dr warren farrell talking about
telomeres if she hasn't boys without
father involvement by agent and if
shortened lifespans fatherlessness is
that serious
henry luizi child support is not 200
pounds it's a percentage of your income
meaning that women who get pregnant by
the right guy have seven seven hundred
pounds to a thousand pounds a month a
month which equates to thirteen hundred
dollars it is a paycheck in the west um
b mackel sign language stop asking her
wendell coven can we get a call and
call it can we get a call-in show pearl
um actually whenever we figure out the
audio issues if there's any producers
watching this feel free to call in and
help us honestly yeah we're trying to
figure it out yeah there's a lot of
yeah yeah we don't we don't know how to
do it um
zantians to the woman who said her
friends aren't getting child support you
mean the same deadbeat men who are bad
boys and won't make good fathers that
they all shared there are good men who
want kids just not someone else's amina
dana just because you simply insist
because the child is here i must double
insist that's a silly argument sentience
if you are the leader and have the
authority to make final decisions you
have the responsibility to leave lead
properly so if the woman has
ultimate authority on child birth
shouldn't she have ultimate
responsibility um wes m a woman who play
that plays the victim also plays the
victim in court no offense if i was her
husband i would be sleeping with one eye
open has to be walking on eggshells
because he knows what would happen not
my real name even though i i don't agree
with her you have to give kudos to the
woman in the corner for arguing her
ideas in a room where everyone disagrees
with her janice porgal birth giving
birth should be 50 50 but all men but
men don't have a say one antonio 35 if
they're if there was more stay-at-home
moms would there be less street slash
gang violence um or no mass shootings if
those stay-at-home moms created
community schools carlos baum tempo it
would be nice if you read the super
chats during the conversation
they would be in context and make sense
so guys i did
there's pros and cons of reading the
super chat conversation and in my
personal opinion the quality of the
conversation is what i prioritize um i
think that's what makes the show really
different from other shows is we're not
constantly interrupting the conversation
to read the super chats we've tested a
couple things we might change it in the
future you know who knows but that's
just the direction we're going right now
so um thank you all for coming special
thanks to you um we had a couple more
chats we're gonna read them i'm gonna
let them go around and then um i'll read
the last super chats at the end so um i
know it's not easy being in a room with
people that disagree and i know the
comments can be harsh so i actually
quite enjoy it yeah
so i do
so
yeah so i do appreciate you coming to a
room of people that disagree with you so
go around any final thoughts and where
people can find you on the socials then
we'll do the last super chats at the end
okay
yeah yeah okay so i'm nana evans and you
can find me on your aunties could never
podcast there's four of us in the
podcast and we discuss current affairs
social issues we do dilemmas we're um
what we would call zenials and we've
lived a little bit and we all have
various different points of views on
relationships so you can find me there
on youtube and on instagram your aunties
could never
um yeah i just want to say thank you um
this was a great show um i really
enjoyed it uh you can find me on take
talk jesse praise underscore and i
recently started a youtube channel um
jessepro shorts so follow me on there
great um i would say first thank you
pearl for having us and thank you for
always
bringing hot topics and controversial
topics and uh yeah you can find me in
instagram with iman and disco dg
i love people it's um rants you can find
me um at random answers on all the
platforms youtube
instagram even got tiktok now
i don't know why but it bangs in it um
twitter as well and yeah madame wrap up
the streets are cold fam
so nice we had to do it twice thank you
for having us from after having us
yesterday um
you can find us at the domino effect pod
i'm daley um that's domino effect pod
and everything tick tock instagram we've
had sarah garvey on there
he attacked a few women pearly's going
to come in there and cause her havoc as
well so if you want to see more havoc
but you want to see i'm more hood styled
and yeah come jump on domino effect pod
yeah second half the domino of it but
thank you again for having us um it's a
great conversation both yesterday and
today
um so yeah apart from the domino effect
you can find me on oba underscore vbe on
instagram and tick tock
um okay yeah thank you all for coming
also guys this is the first time we've
had uh our 2 000 live viewers in the
chat
so like like the video on your way out
um
and let me read i think was there was
there just one other super chat that i
missed i believe so you might have to
refresh it okay i'm gonna refresh it
real quick just to make sure yeah so um
nah says the bible says she's a demon
okay thank you thank you
thank you for that one on the way out
okay also guys don't forget to sign up
for memberships i put jess in charge of
exclusive behind-the-scenes content so
you'll see uh this weekend ish had to
buy us dinner because he lost a bet on
when we would hit a hundred thousand
subscribers so you can get behind the
scenes content um that video is probably
gonna come out when should we drop it
friday makes a saturday yeah when jess
is back when jess comes back
um okay guys don't forget to like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and i will talk to you next time